Weckt mal jetzt mit Osama Bin Laden und Innes Le und Tralala.
Dann dürft ihr mal ein bisschen Versperrungsfühlen.
Die Briten wieder unterdrücken wieder die Diskussion.
Und zwar müssen wir überabwarten.
Also ich hab immer noch ein Problem, wenn der Tim spricht.
In dem Moment, wo ich jetzt rede, machen eure Mikrofone komplett zu.
Das heißt, ich soll's morgen halten.
Sonst setzt's was.
Warum machen wir den Scheiß noch mal?
Ich muss gerade mein Herzrasen unterdrücken.
Leider bin ich immer noch mit demselben Team geschlagen.
Die Transaction-Fees müssen hochgehen.
Oder?
Die Stromkosten müssen runtergehen.
Die Hardwarekosten müssen runtergehen.
Oder?
Der Preis muss steigen.
Exactly.
Das ist auch eine ganze Menge Parameter, an denen man drehen kann. Ich meine, beim Strom...
Ja, bei Strom und Preis der Hardware ist alles so... Da kannst du nicht mehr so viel drehen, aber die Bitcoins müssen halt, die werden einfach mehr wert. Sonst lohnt es sich nicht mehr. Oder was noch passieren kann ist, die Leute steigen aus, weil es sich nicht mehr lohnt. Was passiert, wenn Leute aussteigen und keine Bitcoins mehr meinen? Die Difficulty sinkt wieder und dann lohnt es sich wieder mehr. Dafür ist die Difficulty ja da.
Also letztlich ist dieses ganze Mitrechnen und Erzeugen genau derselbe Zockermarkt, wie ich irgendwie kaufen, verkaufen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Auf eine andere Art und Weise.
Irgendwo schon. Du musst ja Vertrauen auch in diese Währung haben und so weiter. Also am Anfang war es ja noch, als ich damit angefangen habe, da war es halt noch so Mitmachen und Teil der Währung halt mit erstellen. Man war dabei, ist so wie früher die erste IP auf seinen eigenen Rechner nach Hause geholt. Ich habe auch mal ein paar Bitcoins erstellt. Ich glaube, mein Pool hat jetzt 350 Blöcke gefunden. Das sind schon so ein paar tausend Bitcoins. Ist halt der Anteil von meinem Pool. Ich selber habe, glaube ich, ein paar gefunden. Ist schon lange her. Ich glaube, ich habe mit meinen Grafikkarten insgesamt, mein Zähler ist bei 21 Blöcken. Also wenn das jetzt noch alles 50er Blöcke wären, also wenn man 50 Bitcoins kriegt, dann wären es ja schon tausend Bitcoins, aber ich habe natürlich auch ganz schön viel ausgegeben.
Früher.
Damals hat man noch dachte, pff.
Genau. Für iPhones zum Beispiel. Oder für Room 77. Mit meinem Kumpel war ich da essen. Zwei Burger, ein bisschen Cola oder so. Vier Bitcoins, 50 oder so was in dem Dreh.
Wie viel Schmuck trägt der jetzt eigentlich da? Ist da schon irgendwie alles aus Gold und Platin? Der muss doch da irgendwie Bitcoins eingestrichen haben.
Der hat wahrscheinlich, so wie alle auch, immer mal wieder Bitcoins verkauft. Du siehst ja, wie der Markt... Es werden ja nicht nur welche gekauft, sondern da muss ja auch immer ein Verkäufer da sein. Und ich meine, so ist es genauso mit...
Der hat sie alle im Schrank eingesperrt.
Hat er ausgesorgt.
Ich meine, von Bürgern irgendwie sich sein Leben zu finanzieren, das gelingt nur Ronald McDonald und...
Und Room 77 ohne.
Ich meine, der Gedanke ist geil.
Oder ich meine mal ehrlich, das erste Mal...
Ich hab so eine kleine Burger-Bude, bin dadurch Milliardär geworden. Ja echt, was? Was kosten immer dir die Burger? Naja, manche haben so 3000 Euro bezahlt.
Ich glaub, da hat bestimmt schon jemand mal... Ich sag ja eigentlich so, schon die ganze Zeit, das Beste überhaupt ist, du machst eine Bitcoinsenke. Irgendwas, du verkaufst was für Bitcoins und kriegst einfach die in deine Wallet reingespült und vercheckst was dafür. Und dann wird das ganze Scheiß in deiner Wallet einfach automatisch mehr wert in sehr kurzer Zeit. Und ja, fertig ist die Laube. Also es ist auf jeden Fall viel besser als irgendwie zu meinen oder irgendwie da sich jetzt teure Hardware jetzt noch zu kaufen.
So und dann noch was, wenn Leute denken, sie können sich da irgendwie Hardware kaufen und Gewinn machen, dann müsstest du mal so sehen, wenn ihr da eine Hardware kauft, die, was heißt der Kurs jetzt, die 700 Euro teuer ist, das heißt ja genauso gut, ihr könntet von diesen 700 Euro gerade ein Bitcoin kaufen, dann heißt es auch genau, dass diese Hardware euch mindestens ein Bitcoin einbringen muss, sonst lohnt sich die Sache nicht. Also das müsst ihr mit einberechnen, einfach nur sagen, ja der hat ja jetzt was eingebracht, weil die Bitcoins in einem Jahr irgendwie 3000 Euro wert sind, so zählt das nicht, weil dann könnt ihr den Bitcoin jetzt auch direkt kaufen und dann ist er in einem Jahr die 3000 Euro wert, also die Gewinnsteigerung der Bitcoins dürft ihr in eurem Dings nicht mit einberechnen.
Diese Transaction Fees, die sind ja alle freiwillig.
Da ist so ein Algorithmus dahinter, der das bestimmt.
Und zwar ist der die Transaction, also eigentlich soll es ja frei sein, aber die müssen die Blockchain schützen vor DOS-Attacken und vor allen möglichen Attacken. Und zwar, dass du da die Chats mit deiner, dass du über die Blockchain mit deiner Freundin chattest, weil das wäre ja möglich. Du schiebst einfach einen dauernden Bitcoin hinterher und packst irgendwie eine Nachricht rein, wir heiraten bald, ich liebe dich, tralala und so weiter, weißt schon. Und das wollen die natürlich nicht, weil man soll die Blockchain nicht missbrauchen. Und damit das nicht geht, wird eine kleine Transaction-Fee verlangt. Aber damit halt trotzdem weiterhin es möglich sein soll, Transactions zu machen, die nichts kosten, ist, wenn du Bitcoins durch die Gegend schiebst, die schon sehr alt sind. Das heißt, wo die letzte Transaction, wo die herkommen, wenn das schon lange her ist, dann musst du keine Transaction-Fee bezahlen. Wenn die aber ganz frisch sind, die Bitcoins, nämlich wenn du den ein Euro zu deiner Freundin geschoben hast mit der Nachricht, dann ist, war das ja erst mal alt, hast du das vielleicht umsonst die erste Nachricht geschickt. Aber bei, wenn deine Freundin dann den Bitcoin hat, ist der ja nicht mehr alt, der ist ja dann frisch, weil sie hat ihn ja gerade erst bekommen. Das heißt, wenn sie den gleichen Bitcoin dann wieder schickt, dann musst du schon eine Transaction-Fee bezahlen. So, und dann gibt es noch, wenn du, sei es das Alter des Bitcoins ist wichtig für die Transaction-Fee, dann noch die Größe der Transaction. Das heißt, wenn du ganz, ganz viele kleine Satoshi-Summen hast, also mal so 0,0000001 und hier nochmal 0,0002 und die alle zusammenfasst zu einer größeren Transaction, weil du die irgendwo hinschiebst, so wie wahrscheinlich der Satoshi-Klein-Typie das machen muss mit seiner Lotterie da, dann wird ja die Transaction so byte-mäßig größer. Also die Menge, die in der Blockchain gespeichert wird. Und wenn das eine gewisse Größe überschreitet, dann musst du da auch irgendwie eine Transaction-Fee bezahlen. Und ich glaube, umso größer die werden, umso mehr. Bin mir aber jetzt nicht ganz so sicher. Und ich glaube, da war irgendwas noch was Drittes, was bestimmt, ob da eine Transaction-Fee draufkommt oder nicht. Also damit wollen sie verhindern, dass halt Leute Spiele reiten und mit Transactions machen.
Aber trotzdem gibt es ja noch so diese freiwillige Geschichte, trotzdem eine zu zahlen, auch wenn es eigentlich nicht passt.
Ja, das ist ja jeder Pool. Also jetzt sind es ja eigentlich fast nur noch Pools, die halt Blöcke mine. Also es gibt vielleicht noch ein paar welche, die das sogenannte Solo-Mining machen, also ohne Pool. Die können ja bestimmen, welche Transaction sie aufnehmen und in ihren Blog einbauen, den sie berechnen und welche nicht. Und mein Pool nimmt einfach den Standard Bitcoin-Client und da ist es halt so eingegeben. Und wenn du jetzt...
Ist was eingegeben?
Na, diese Algorithmus, der checkt, ob er eine Transaction nimmt oder nicht. Und ich weiß gar nicht, also was der da, wie es genau eingestellt ist. Also wahrscheinlich so, wie ich gerade gesagt habe. Aber es könnten natürlich auch Pool-Betreiber geben, die das ausschalten und die sagen, okay, wir nehmen alle Transactions, egal ob die Fees haben oder nicht, ist uns total wurscht, wir nehmen die. Dann könnte es sein, dass wenn einer halt eine Transaction macht, wo eigentlich eine Fee drin sein müsste nach dem Standard-Algorithmus und da aber keine reinsetzt, dass der von diesen Pools dann trotzdem mit in den aktuellen Block reingerechnet wird. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es glaube ich auch Pools, hier dieser, wie heißt der Typ, Luke Junior heißt er, der hat diesen Eligios-Pool, wo man als Absender-Adresse gleich seine Wallet-Adresse macht, damit er keine User-Verwaltung hat. Man kriegt das dann immer so automatisch überwiesen. Und der hat gesagt, er findet hier halt ohne Fees, findet er blöd. Also es ist jetzt schon lange her, wo ich das gehört habe, ich weiß nicht, ob er das immer noch so macht. Und der will immer diese Transaction-Fee, weil er meint, Leute, das soll nicht ganz umsonst sein, weil dafür macht er die Arbeit ja oder irgendwie so. Und der nimmt keine Transactions, die halt keine Fee dabei haben. Das heißt, sein Pool berechnet die nicht und nimmt die einfach nicht auf. Und wenn sein Pool gerade den Block gefunden hat, dann ist da keine Transaction dabei, die keine Fee hat. Da muss deine Transaction warten, bis ein anderer Pool die aufnimmt, die Transaction und das mit reinpackt. Deswegen dauert es bei manchen Transactions ein bisschen länger, bis die ankommen, weil es erstmal in den Block mit reingepackt werden musste. Nee, du brauchst da diese Confirmations. Und man muss erstmal in so einen Block rein, das kann eine Weile dauern und ab da dann die nächsten 6 Block und dann ist es ja erst confirmed, dass du eine Transaction gemacht hast.
Ja, aber kann ich dadurch jetzt irgendeinen finanziellen Schaden erleiden?
Nee, finanziell nicht, das dauert halt nur.
Du musst da halt drei Tage da im Room 77 sitzen, bis er dich gehen lässt.
Und wenn jetzt irgendwie auch einmal alle, also angenommen es gibt jetzt auch keine Bitcoins mehr zu berechnen und es geht jetzt einfach nur noch um das Transaktionsgeld, dann könnten ja auch alle sich so kartellmäßig zusammensetzen und sagen, ja ohne Transaktionsgebühr geht hier keine Bitcoin durch.
Korrekt.
Und dann haben wir wieder die Herrschaft der Banken.
Nee, wenn die dann langsamer Bitcoins berechnen, was passiert, wenn weniger als 2014 Bitcoins in zwei Wochen berechnet werden, was passiert dann? Dann sinkt die Difficulty wieder.
Achso.
Dann wird es einfacher und dann können andere das wieder machen, weil es sich dann für die mehr lohnt.
Weil es wieder mehr Konkurrenz gibt. Das ist wirklich absurd, wie sich das ganze System so nivelliert und umso länger dieser Spaß geht, umso mehr Aspekte dabei rauskommen, umso faszinierter bin ich davon, dass ich das wirklich mal...
Dass es immer noch funktioniert.
Dass es erst mal funktioniert, aber dass auch wirklich so viel Weitblick da am Anfang war, dass überhaupt diese ganzen Dimensionen und Ausprägungen zu erfassen. Weil, ich meine, das meiste von dem, worüber wir jetzt reden, ist ja im Prinzip konzeptionelle Arbeit von Anfang an. Da ist jetzt nicht irgendwie, es mussten sich später Konventionen einpendeln, wie das halt so gemacht wird, sondern es ist einfach systemimmanentes Grundverhalten und wenn irgendwas davon in eine falsche Richtung mündet, dann könnte es halt sein, dass der ganze Apparat zusammenstürzt und das passiert irgendwie noch nicht.
Nee, ich meine, kann man sich ausrechnen jetzt, wie viel tausend Dollar waren es jetzt gerade, ja? Und es gibt 12 Millionen Bitcoins, das heißt, es sind 12 Milliarden Euro, richtig? Dollar, 12 Milliarden Dollar wert. Bei 12 Milliarden Dollar, die dieser Markt wert ist, wenn man den halt hackt oder eine Lücke findet, das wäre schon ganz schön viel Geld und bisher hat es noch keiner gemacht oder gefunden.
Oder zumindest nicht bescheid gesagt.
Also bei 12 Milliarden Dollar, ich hätte Bescheid gesagt. Oder nicht bescheid gesagt, sondern ich hätte mehr Bitcoins besorgt oder wie auch immer oder abgestoßen oder...
Wie viele Bitcoins gibt es?
Na zurzeit 12 Millionen. Ja, wie gesagt, die ersten 50 Prozent aller Bitcoins wurden in den ersten vier Jahren gemeint. 12 Millionen und 45.000.
Die ersten 80?
Die ersten, wie viel gibt es? 21 Millionen Bitcoins gibt es insgesamt. Die ersten 10,5 Millionen Bitcoins wurden in den ersten vier Jahren gemeint. Das ist in der Zeit, wo die Blöcke 50 Bitcoins ausgespuckt haben. Danach hat sich es ja halbiert. Seitdem gibt es nur noch halb so viele Bitcoins.
10 Millionen Bitcoins. Wie viele Leute dürften daran beteiligt gewesen sein in diesen ersten vier Jahren?
Nein, in den ersten zwei Jahren waren es irgendwie keine 1000, glaube ich.
Das ist schon eine interessante Umverteilung, die da stattgefunden hat.
Ja, aber wie man ja auch gelesen hat, sind so eine Bitcoins auf dem Müll gelandet. Wie der Typ, dem jetzt eingefallen ist, da gab es so einen, habe ich gerade vorhin gelesen, hat irgendwie seine alte Festplatte weggeschmissen und so und dann fiel ihm später ein Scheiße. Da waren ja damals noch irgendwie, ich habe noch mal auch Bitcoins gerechnet, 7500 Bitcoins angeblich sollen da drauf sein. Und die hat er im Juli auf irgendeine Müllhalde, müsste es gelandet sein.
7500 Bitcoins?
Und die liegen jetzt irgendwo auf der Müllhalde.
7,5 Millionen Euro auf die Müllhalde geschmissen.
7500 Bitcoins?
Achso, ja, ne, das ist recht.
Ja, wenn die Story denn stimmt, vielleicht will er ja auch nur, dass einmal sein Müllberg in seiner Umgebung da einmal umgeschaufelt wird. Ich hab auch mal 10.000 Bitcoins verloren, und zwar direkt unterm Reichstag, Jungs.
Mein Herz.
Was ist denn mit diesen Lite-Coins und diesen ganzen anderen Coins, die jetzt irgendwie auch noch aufkommen und irgendwie das Gleiche aber anders machen?
Ja, Trittbett-Frage.
Aber da steigen die Preise auch.
Ja, früher konnte man halt nicht nur Bitcoins machen, sondern gab es ja ganz viele alternative Währungen, Alternate-Coins heißen die. Und Lite-Coins ist irgendwie das bekannteste davon. Die benutzen kein Chart-2 zum Haschen, weil Bitcoin nutzt ja so ein Doppelschar-Dings, sondern die benutzen S-Kript. Und das hat den Nachteil, den gewollten von denen, dass man dafür auch Memory braucht. Das heißt, das kann man nicht so einfach mit einer Grafikkarte FPGA oder ASIC berechnen. Das wollten die nämlich irgendwie nicht, dass da Leute mit cooler Hardware einen Vorsprung haben. Sie wollten, dass es einfach immer weiterhin mit CPU gemacht werden muss oder irgendwie so. Und das hat sich halt so entwickelt. Und Lite-Coins ist, glaube ich, noch, wie gesagt, die größte und bekannteste. Die anderen sind, glaube ich, inzwischen alle schon abgestorben. Wie gesagt, das sind alles Trittbettfahrer. Ich habe mich nie mit Lite-Coins beschäftigt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da wirklich einen Markt gibt oder ob man da irgendwo was sinnvoll von kaufen kann. Irgendwo ist auf jeden Fall reichlich Kleinheit Bitcoin, aber schwimmen halt immer noch im Schatten. Und früher gab es halt auch, du konntest natürlich deine Lite-Coins gegen Bitcoins tauschen und andersrum und so. Und ja.
Also Lite-Coin, der Klein sieht genauso aus wie der Bitcoin-Klein, übrigens der QT-Klein.
Die haben nur diese Hashing Engine da getauscht. Der Rest kann ja so bleiben. Haben einen anderen Genesys-Block, wie der heißt. Der erste Block, den man halt findet, ist bei Lite-Coin halt ein anderer. Und ansonsten baut sich da eine andere Blockchain an.
Also der einzige Market, dem ich da einigermaßen vertrauen würde, ist ja dieser BTC-E, der irgendwie Lite-Coins und Bitcoins tradet. Aber da hab ich es auch noch nicht ausprobiert. Und wie man die meint, ist irgendwie auch unklar. Falls irgendwelche Hörer eine gute Anleitung haben, wie man Lite-Coins meint, könnt ihr das ja mal in den Kommentaren hinterlassen. Irgendwie ist das so ein bisschen unklar, wie man die eigentlich daher meint. Und für tolle Charts, also wer sich da so den aktuellen mag und was da so passiert angucken will, bitcoinwisdom.com ist irgendwie so der coole Chartbrowser, der das schön visualisiert.
Alles mögliche kann man sich da anschauen. Auch der Verlauf dieser Difficulty.
Die Hashrate geht auch steil nach oben.
Also auch irgendwie abstrakter geht es ja auch fast überhaupt nicht mehr. Also ich fand Aktienmärkte und solche Börsen sowieso schon immer mega abstrakt. Aber jetzt das Ganze dann auch noch auf Basis nur von so...
Ja, aber bei einer Aktie ist ja fast noch... Das kann man ja fast noch verstehen. Da ist der Wert halt irgendwie...
Wir sind halt ja Freak Show, ne?
So bei Apple, da kannst du gucken, alles klar, demnächst kommt ein neues iPhone und sie werden wahrscheinlich Ferien verkaufen und alles klar, der Kurs steigt. Oder hier irgendwie Antennagate total auf Lob und Aktie stört demnächst ab. Und so, das kannst du ja noch irgendwie sauber bei Bitcoin. Also das geht ja gar nicht.
Also ich meine, so Gerüchteküche, dass jetzt irgendwie eBay Bitcoin verwenden möchte und so...
Meinst du jetzt bei New York kommt der neue Burger raus und die werden jetzt mehr Bitcoins ausgeben? Das kann man ja nicht so sagen.
Was kann man nicht wie sagen?
Also hinter der Währung steckt ja keiner.
Ja, hinter der Währung steckt das, was der allen Währung steckt, nämlich Erwartungen und Vertrauen. Und in dem Moment, wo man das Vertrauen hat in eine Währung und dann eben auch noch bestimmte Erwartungen hat, dann ändert sich halt der Wert davon, den du ihm beimisst. Und genauso ist das bei Bitcoin auch. Von daher sehe ich hier überhaupt gar keinen großen Unterschied. Aber in dem Moment, wo halt größere Unternehmen von Rang, wie zum Beispiel Ebay, auch nur so mit der Braue lupfen und sagen, so Bitcoin können wir uns nicht ausschließen. Genau, kann nicht komplett ausgeschlossen werden. Dann steigt, wie man so schön sagt, die Fantasie. Also alle können sich auf einmal vorstellen das und sind dann erwartungsfroh. Du bist jetzt bei Bitcoin-Preis X und deine Erwartung ist, dass werden doch die anderen jetzt auch alle toll finden. Also liegt der Preis bestimmt in einer Woche bei X mal 2. Wenn ich jetzt X kaufe, habe ich danach 100 Prozent gewinnen. Wie bei einer normalen Aktie auch. Und das ist dann jetzt auch kein anderes Event, als Apple hat sein iPhone verkackt oder so. Wobei bei Apple, wenn die was bekannt geben...
Ja, aber doch bei Apple oder bei Firmen ist halt der Firmenwert auch noch mit dahinter als Stützung.
Ja, aber auch der Firmenwert errechnet sich ja letztlich auch nur da draus. Also deine Market-Capitalization, die ist ja der Aktienwert mal Aktien. Und mehr ist es ja auch nicht. Also dieses Apple ist mehr wert als jede andere Firma. Ist ja insofern totaler Quatsch, als dass jetzt nicht Buchhalter gekommen sind und mal zusammen gerechnet haben, was man für diese Fabriken so kaufen könnte und was bei Tim Cook noch so in der Brieftasche steckt. Sondern das ist auch nur Aktienwert mal aktueller Preis ist Valuierung so. Aber die Valuierung kann halt am nächsten Tag dann auch gleich wieder ganz woanders hin zeigen. Und von daher ist das halt auch irgendwie alles gaga.
Deswegen sagen die auch immer undervalued.
Ja, genau. Und was sie nicht alles sagen. Und sie sagen die merkwürdigsten Sachen, gerade über Apple werden die merkwürdigsten Sachen gesagt. Da gab es jetzt gerade so einen schönen Link, irgendwie 29 Aussagen von Finanzleuten. Ja, eine davon war auch irgendwie, irgendwas sei ja ein Ponzi-Scheme, das hast du ja jetzt auch schon benutzt irgendwie.
Im Kommentar ist fast nie irgendwas ein Ponzi-Scheme, wenn es irgendwie als solches benannt wird. Ich kann das jetzt gar nicht herleiten.
Ja, aber dann auch irgendwie so... meets expectations, wie war das, nicht meets expectations, sondern übersteigt die expectations und so. Alles totaler Quatsch. Und ich glaube, dieser ganze Finanzmarkt ist auch einfach, gehört eigentlich verboten. Das ist alles so schlimm und alles so virtuell und alles so in keinem Verhältnis zu realen Werten. Ich meine, wir lächeln jetzt hier so ein bisschen über solche Spekulationsgewinne. Oder der eine oder andere freut sich dann vielleicht auch, wenn er es richtig gemacht hat. Und klar ist das cool. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, irgendjemand war jetzt mal wirklich so krasser Linux-Nerd. Und die gibt es bestimmt. Die so zwei Eigenschaften mit sich gebracht haben. Nämlich eins, weiß er Tag eins, dass es das gibt. Bitcoin wird irgendwie das Paper rausgehauen. Dann war das wahrscheinlich irgendwo drei Tage später auf Slashdot.
Nee, am gleichen Tag, also er hat es auf die Cypher-Punks-Mail-Liste gepackt. Irgendwie so, ja. Oder so eine Kryptoliste oder so.
Und dann ist ein Tag später auf Slashdot.
Nee, das war ja zwei Jahre später.
Dann ist er halt auf der Cypher-Punks-Mail-Liste. Oder auch zwei Jahre später, hätte ja auch völlig gereicht. Ja, sagen wir mal, das Ding ist irgendwie auf Slashdot. Dollar Linux Nerd setzt sich hin und denkt sich, ich hab ja eigentlich ganz ordentlich Grafikkarten irgendwie am Wurf. Ich compile mir das mal, ich fahr das mal. Bumm, so, macht einfach mit. Und hat dann sich irgendwie seine 50.000 Bitcoins zusammen gemeint, für die er wahrscheinlich so jetzt einen Hamburger kaufen könnte. Und der Kack läuft einfach durch und bot sich in der Nase und kümmert sich nicht drum. Und jetzt fällt ihm irgendwie auf, wie viel hab ich denn da eigentlich zusammen gerechnet? Irgendwie läuft da noch so ein Prozess, wie auf meinem Server hinten im Schlafzimmer. So und dann hoppala und dann irgendwie ausgesorgt.
Also da gab es immer so einen Typen, wenn ich das hier in den Irk-Chats, das gibt es ja diesen Bitcoin-Developer-Channel, da gab es immer einen Typen, von dem haben die viel geredet. Der hat sich für seine Grafikkarten, also hier schon so Anfang 2011 oder vielleicht sogar schon Ende 2010, hat für das OpenCale halt sich da so einen, wie heißt das, so einen Kernel geschrieben, der halt Bitcoins berechnet. Und ich glaube, der war halt so drauf und hat den halt nicht rausgerückt. Das heißt, der war der einzige und alleinige Typ, der am Anfang mit Grafikkarten auf OpenCale-Basis irgendwie Bitcoins berechnen konnte ohne Ende. Zumindest reichlich schneller und billiger als mit einer CPU. Und ja, der war lange viel im Chat und dann aber auch nicht mehr, weil ich weiß nicht, was er dann gemacht hat. Vielleicht war er schon im Urlaub oder was auch immer hat sich abgesetzt, aber der hat wahrscheinlich richtig verdient. Weil wenn du was hast, was schneller ist als die restliche Hardware, dann kannst du ja immer richtig ordentlich abgreifen. Nee, Grafikkarte ist vorbei, Tim. FPGAs ist alles vorbei. Nur noch Asics und selbst da gehen sie gerade. Die KNC-Firma hier ist jetzt dieser, was haben wir geguckt, dieser Napton mit diesen drei Terrainstellern, der nächstes Jahr rauskommen soll, der ist bei 20 Nanometer schon. Also der kleinste Asic, den sie gerade bauen. Und die anderen haben bei 60 angefangen oder so. Die sind jetzt bei 20. Intel ist bei 14. Also die sind nicht mehr so weit weg von Intel. Und wenn die da richtig die dicke Mark machen, wahrscheinlich rufen die demnächst bei Intel an und sagen, ey Jungs, ist ja alles ganz geil, was ihr habt. Wir wollen auch mal eure 14 Nanometer Fabrik mieten. Wir müssen da mal ein paar Asics irgendwie durchschieben.
Aber ich meine, die ganzen Leute, die jetzt da diese Bitcoin-Meine-Hardware bauen, die bauen die doch bestimmt in China. Und die Chinesen, die sitzen jetzt so da und haben jetzt auch ihren eigenen Market und so. Und die lassen sich da jetzt einfach mal aus und ein paar Asics-Boards.
Und fällt ab und zu mal so ein Chip an der Seite runter, meinst du?
Demnächst gibt es einfach keine Macs und keine iPhones mehr, weil Foxconn komplett irgendwie nur noch auf Bitcoin-Mining umgestellt hat.
Ja, aber dann verdient ja keiner mehr was.
Na die machen ja auch keine Fabs. Aber hier so, keine Ahnung, gibt auf einmal keine Armsteine mehr. Oder Apple stellt einfach seine Produkte ein.
Samsung sagt hier zu Apple, ja danke, wir haben ja besseren Kunden.
Oder Apple stellt einfach seine Produkte ein, weil sie irgendwie rausgefunden haben, wie sie jetzt Bitcoins minen können.
Das sind wir leider komplett mit ausgelastet, glaube ich nicht. Da können wir jetzt keine neuen kurzen Säule rausnehmen.
Was mir auch noch per Twitter hier gedingst wurde, ist, dass es hier von dieser Firma AS. Rock oder so, also nicht AS ist, sondern AS. Rock heißt die so, so eine Motherboard-Firma. Rock? Die Motherboard. Mutter Bördchen. Die Motherboard haben, wo mehrere PCI-Slots so fett sind, dass man halt vier Grafikkarten oder noch mehr nebeneinander machen kann. Aber ich meine, sie sind auch ein bisschen spät irgendwie im Spiel, weil Grafikkarte ist halt vorbei.
Also mehrere 16x-Lanes sozusagen.
Nee, du brauchst eigentlich nur eine Lane. Das ist das Problem, da geht ja gar nicht so viel rüber, weil die müssen ja nur die ganze Zeit rechnen. Also so Memory Transfer muss gar nicht schnell sein, aber du brauchst halt viel Abstand zwischen den Lanes, weil sonst kriegt die Grafikkarte keine Luft. Also die Grafikkarte sind ja eh doppeltig, die belegen ja eh zwei Slots. Und wenn dann aber schon die nächste kommt, könnten die nicht atmen. Das ist schlecht. Und die hatten irgendwie so ein fettes Wo, dass irgendwie alles schicker, besser und toller ist und so. Aber wie gesagt, es braucht keinen Schwein mehr, weil Grafikkarte ist vorbei.
Also die Leute beschweren sich ja nach wie vor über den Stream, ne?
Ja, soll wohl knarzen, sagt man mir.
Und nicht nur du, sondern alle. So eine tolle iPhone-App, die auch Icecast kann. Wir könnten ja versuchen, über das iPhone zu streamen. Achso, aber du hast ja Username und Passwort, das kann man hier wieder nicht eingeben. Oder vielleicht gleich in der URL, schon mit Doppelpunkt und so. Okay, ihr müsst das einfach vertragen. Hört euch im Zweifel das nochmal als Aufnahme an. Die App, die ich jetzt hier habe, die kann irgendwie nicht Username und Passwort oder so. Das ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. So, Tim steigt nochmal auf.
Da hat sich wieder die Ärmel ohne Grenzen geteilt.
Warum resolvt gerade der Google-DNS nicht? Geht denn heutzutage wirklich gar nichts mehr ordentlich? Das ist doch wirklich furchtbar. Oder ist das Tims IPv6? Wahrscheinlich Letzteres.
Ich glaub, ich brauch einfach mal hier so einen Yamaha-Nerd.
Yamaha-Nerd? Yamaha-Nerd?
Einfach ansatzfrei, das ist das Problem. Und ich kenne mittlerweile durch diesen ganzen Kram, also ich kenne das mittlerweile sogar halbwegs gut hier. Den ganzen Kram, ich versteh das. Ich kann nicht ausschließen, dass hier keiner einen groben Fehler gemacht hat, aber ich weiß halt einfach nicht.
Also jetzt habt ihr das davon. Jetzt konfiguriert Tim live und in Farbe.
Jetzt müsst ihr immer wieder ein paar Themen bringen.
Ich kann ja mal erwähnen, dass ich am 19. Dezember ein Konzert spiele.
So schlecht ist die Musik jetzt auch nicht.
Das allererste Konzert von meiner Band in Berlin. Es ist sogar kostenlos der Eintritt. Und alle, also es können nicht alle kommen, die hier zuhören.
Machst du dann Stage Diving auch?
Wann ist das, wenn alle kommen? Macht einer auf Facebook hier so einen?
Ist das schon auf Facebook?
Dann kommen alle.
Also der Club ist zugelassen für, glaube ich, 250 Leute. Facebook-Party! Wir müssen erstmal gucken, ob ihr da in Berlin seid und so weiter. Aber es ist durchaus möglich, ich pack mal den Link. Der ist ja ein Facebook-Event. Pack ich mal einen Chat, dann könnt ihr da auf Join klicken. Und wenn es zu viele werden, dann kann ich immer noch...
Absagen.
Nee, dann kann ich immer noch sowas machen wie, ihr müsst euch jetzt noch einen Token klicken oder so. Und wer zu spät kommt, den bestraft das Leben. Aber das wäre auf jeden Fall eine Gelegenheit, in Berlin mal Kontakt mit dem einen oder anderen Teilnehmer dieses Podcasts auch aufzunehmen. Also der Event heißt Initial Eruption, weil die Band White Volcano heißt. Da gibt's den Event im Chat und später in den Show Notes, für die, die gerade zuhören. Wir haben noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Programm, aber deswegen ist es auch kostenlos, kann sich keiner beschweren.
Und was macht ihr so für Musik?
Also Stromgitarrenmusik.
Und Cover oder eigene? Als eigene? Und wer macht das?
Achso, wir haben keine Texte. Instrumental Rock.
Psychedelic Rock.
Auch, ja. Psychedelic Rock ist ja... Das ist noch am ehesten das, aber wir spielen irgendwie ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Aber es gibt auch so einen Soundcloud-Link, kann ich ja auch mal gleich posten, von einer frühen Aufnahme vor einem halben Jahr oder so. Und hab ich ja auch schon mal gepostet. Haben ja sogar Leute schon auf Bandcamp gekauft. Ja, so ähnlich klingt das. Also es gibt drei Tracks, die poste ich mal hier auch noch in den Chat für die, die es noch nicht gesehen haben. Und dann, ja, sehen wir mal. Da gibt es auf jeden Fall ein paar Songs mehr. Und Bier und Spaß. Warme Herzen in kalten Jahreszeiten. So, senden wir noch Tim?
Ja, cool. Also nicht anders als vorher. Ja, ich hab einfach gerade noch mal geguckt, ob ich irgendwie mein System nicht verstehe. Ja, aber ich... Wenn das jetzt auch nicht funktioniert, dann ist es schon das sechste Subsystem, was jetzt irgendwie versagt. Ich verstehe langsam die Welt nicht mehr.
Also, dieses Livestream-Programm, das ist mir auch gerade sofort gecrashed, als ich versucht hab, damit mal zu streamen.
Nice cast.
Na ja, es gibt hier Live Shout, das ist eine iPhone-App. Aber die wollte ich gerade mit meinem Server mal verbinden und da crashts. Oder ist der Server nicht an vielleicht?
Da musst du was anderes nehmen, was gut funktioniert, ist...
Na dann stell das iPhone doch einfach mal in die Mitte und lass das aufs Xenum streamen. Dann hören die da auf, aus den Ohren zu bluten.
Das kannst du auch keinen zumuten. Das geht gar nicht.
Das iPhone-Mikrofon ist ziemlich gut.
Aber wir reden hier leise in unsere Kopfhörer rein.
Das iPhone, das macht das schon.
Bis ich das jetzt hier auf den richtigen Endpoint... Das interessiert jetzt auch die Podcast-Hörer wirklich einen Dreck. Ich versuche ja hier nebenbei noch, während du sinnvolle Sachen sagst, irgendwas zu tun.
So viele sinnvolle Sachen habe ich aber auch gar nicht zu essen.
Da wobei zu philosophieren ist jetzt ein bisschen... Ich guck nur gerade mal Papaya ist die Streaming Software, die ich dir empfehlen würde. Also zwar jetzt vom User Interface. Papaya, also wie die Frucht, die so ein bisschen stinkt. Also ich finde ja Papayas......stinken. Und wenn du das einmal gehört hast, dass sie stinken, selbst wenn du dachtest, dass sie stinken...
Danke Tim, wirklich danke.
Also hier gibt es Papaya Farm, Papaya Club. Rot mit Gelb, es gibt so viele Papaya Apps.
Vielleicht darf es ja nicht unter iOS 7, weiß ich nicht.
Papaya Play.
Es wird berichtet, dass es Knarzen oder was auch immer jetzt besser wäre, also weg wäre.
Sagt wer?
Unterstrom.
Ok, nächstes Thema.
Was nehmen wir denn da?
Was hast du jetzt gemacht eigentlich?
Das was weg ist?
Das Knarzen.
Nichts. Wieso ist es weg?
Ja, sagen, alles ist sauber, kein Knarzen mehr.
Oh, ich hab an den Kabeln gewackelt.
Wackelkontakt. Vielleicht war eine Erdung irgendwie nicht richtig dran. Dann hat sich das aufgeladen und ab und zu hat sich dann über das Kabel entladen. Es ist sozusagen übergesprungen, wenn es zu viel wurde. Und das war das Knarzen dann.
Zwei Wochen für den Arsch.
Ich hab mir noch genug Probleme, die alle totally unrelated sind. Ich sag's euch. Nee, ich hab einfach hinten ein bisschen an dem digitalen Zinskabel rumgefummelt. Ach echt, das hat's gebracht. Meine Hände können noch heilen.
Na, noch ein paar Computronen übrig geblieben.
Ja, genau. Auch jetzt kommen wir von Audio zu Bitcoin und von Bitcoin kommen wir jetzt nochmal kurz auf Audio. Weil ich hab ja überhaupt keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute das überhaupt interessiert, aber ich meine, man muss ja auch seine Erfahrungsferien bringen. Die anderen Podcasts unterhalten sich bestimmt über alle die coolen Sachen. Wir reden einfach nur über Bitcoin und Audio. Also, meine Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Audiosystem auf dem Mac, das ist wirklich, ja, also, ich hab da auch so ein paar Einblicke, ich kriege so, ich kriege so aus interessanten Quellen Einblicke in die Realität da. Die Realitäten, die dazu führen, dass das so ist, wie es ist.
Was denn?
Ich kann da nicht sehr viel spezifischer werden.
Kann ich nicht.
Listen. Man kann zu dem Schluss kommen, dass vieles von dem, was wir als schlechte Entscheidungen empfinden, einfach keine Entscheidungen waren. Also sozusagen einfach genug Leute lassen. Weil dieses Apple ist ja irgendwie komisch. Ich meine, die haben so viel Kohle, die könnten sich so viele Programmierer dahinsetzen. Aber das Problem ist, dass sie A, wohl, selbst wenn sie wollten, gar nicht die beliebige Zahl an Programmierern bekommen könnten, die sie haben wollen, weil sie dann wirklich nur die Schönsten und Besten haben wollen. Das ist ja auch so begrenzt. Die kann man sich nicht beliebig meinen, um mal so ein bisschen hier beim Leitmotiv der Sendung zu bleiben. Die kannst du nicht einfach aus dem Nichts herausklöppeln, oder zumindest ist der Aufwand relativ groß. Und abgesehen davon habe ich auch so den Eindruck, dass dieser Laden einfach eine nennenswerte Abneigung hat gegen Größe. Also selbst wenn sie in bestimmten Bereichen wachsen, könnten sie nicht unbedingt davon, dass sie nicht unbedingt glauben, dass mehr Leute auf dasselbe Problem zu schmeißen helfen wird. Also bei diesem Mythical Man-Month mit der Kernaussage, by adding people to a project you make it longer. Und da ist auch sicherlich eine Menge Wahrheit dran. Ob das jetzt immer im Einzelnen so ist, keine Ahnung, wie auch immer. Was ist also jetzt die Realität? Man hat irgendwie dieses halbwegs brauchbare Core-Audio- Subsystem und das hat so ein paar tolle Sachen und ein paar Sachen sind einfach so nicht zu Ende gebaut. Und ich habe mich ja schon ein paar Mal darüber beklagt, dass zum Beispiel so dieser Support für mehrere Kanäle auf einem Interface sehr unterentwickelt ist. Und jetzt gibt es ja dieses Tool hier, dieses Audio-Midi-Setup, wo sie die Konfiguration des Midi- und Audio- Subsystems so abbilden und wenn man dann dieses Audio-Devices Fensterchen aufmacht, dann sieht man alle seine kleinen Audio-Devices und kann wie so in so einem Inspektor sich das irgendwie alles anschauen. Und jetzt hier in meinem System, da ist gleich eine ganze Batterie und das heißt, wenn du dann mehrere Kanäle hast, siehst du jeden Kanal auch einzeln und wenn das Interface auch noch verschiedene Quellen unterscheidet, dann kannst du die auch noch umstellen. Also was sind zum Beispiel Quellen? Das sind so Audiodevices wie mein USB-Device, das ist dieses U24XL, was ich verwende, mit dem ich eigentlich bisher immer ganz glücklich war, aber mit dem ich auch ein Problem habe gerade. So und wenn es reinkommt, dann gibt es halt analoge und spdiff Quellen. Aber es ist nicht vierkanalig, sondern es ist zweikanalig. Das heißt, du schaltest um, ob du das eine oder das andere haben willst und das ist dann Kanal 1 und 2. Aber entweder hast du halt analog 1 und 2 als 1 und 2 oder digital als 1 und 2 und 3 und 4 gibt es nicht. So funktioniert das, so ist das irgendwie auch in Standard-USB-Devices abgebildet. All das kannst du hier in diesem Audio-Devices-Fensterchen einstellen. Außerdem kann man dann noch die Sampling-Frequenz einstellen und teilweise auch noch die interne Auflösung. Also ob das mit 16-Bit oder 24-Bit rechnen soll, ob es Floating-Point machen soll oder nicht. Je nachdem, wie die Interfaces das so vorsehen. Bei manchen ist das irgendwie auch fest eingestellt und bei manchen hast du da eben echt Bandbreite. Also zum Beispiel diese Focus-Rite RedNet-Karte, die ich gekauft habe, die ja mein Dante-Problem eigentlich lösen sollte, aber jetzt wieder mit anderen Produkten.
128 Channels.
Genau, ja, die kann 128 Channels rein und raus. Mit 32-Bit Float-Auflösung bei 48 Kilohertz. Und ich glaube, wenn du sie auf, du kannst dann bis zu 192 Kilohertz hochgehen. Und wenn du irgendwie das machst, hast du nicht mehr ganz so viele Kanäle. Jetzt kann ich das gerade hier irgendwie nicht umstellen. Ich weiß nicht warum. Eine Ahnung, vielleicht muss ich erst die Zahl der Kanäle runterstellen und dann kann ich das machen. Irgendwie so war es, keine Ahnung.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Das ist der Wahnsinn. Na ja, gut, das gibt halt Gigabit einfach so her. Gigabit ist halt einfach mal sehr breitbandig. Da passt einfach eine Menge drauf. Und damit kannst du das dann halt auch irgendwie nutzen. Das ist ja auch genau das, das ist genau das, was mich hier eigentlich so scharf drauf macht. Mit dieser Karte da drin, welche in der Lage ist, hier 128 Kanäle rein und raus zu jagen, mit einer hohen Auflösung, also sowohl mit einer intern hohen Auflösung, eine hohe Sampling-Frequenz und dann auch noch viele Kanäle. Nur, dass es irgendwie fast nie gelingt, diese Kanäle überhaupt zu adressieren. Klar, also in professionellen DAW-Softwaren, Live, Ableton, QBase, etc., da kannst du die dann irgendwie alle nehmen. Da sagst du halt, hier nimm dieses Audio-Interface und da sind deine Kanäle dran. Aber krieg halt mal diese anderen Programme dazu, diese Kanäle irgendwie zu benutzen. Hast du so einen Skype? Kannst du das halt mal nicht sagen, dass er auf Kanal 37 und 38 senden und auf 45 und 46 empfangen soll?
So schön wär das.
Das wär so schön. Genau, das wär so schön. Also allein so was Banales wie, ich spiele einen Jingle ein. So. Und jetzt hab ich hier 16 Kanäle auf meinem Mischpult, die ich so über Ethernet ansprechen kann. Und wenn ich jetzt aber dieser Jingle-Software dieser Bekloppten sagen würde, nimm hier mal das Dante-Interface, dann benutze halt einfach Kanal 1 und 2. Immer. Dann schreibt man die Leute ein und sagt Leute, ihr macht hier Software für Mix-Environments, warum kann ich die scheiß Kanäle einwählen? Nee, machen wir nicht. Muss man dann so retten. Selbe Problem beim Empfang. Deswegen leg ich Rody auch mal in den Ohren, da vielleicht mal so einen virtuellen Treiber zu bauen, mit dem man das irgendwie mapen könnte und ob das überhaupt funktioniert, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab jetzt für den einen Weg tatsächlich einen Weg gefunden, weil wenn man nämlich jetzt diese, wie sag ich es dem Kinder, also wenn du ein Interface auswählst mit mehreren Kanälen oder sagen wir mal alle, die überhaupt erstmal Ausgabekanäle haben, ich nehme jetzt mal eins mit mehreren Kanälen, wie zum Beispiel zum Dante, von dem ich gerade hier gesprochen habe, dann kann ich nicht nur die einzelnen Kanäle irgendwie im Input und Output mir anschauen, nein, dann gibt es auch noch rechts unten so einen Button, der heißt Configure Speakers. Jeder, der da schonmal rumgeklickt hat, irgendwann mal entdeckt und man denkt sich halt immer so, ja, Speakers irgendwie, Lautsprecher, who cares? Und dann machst du das irgendwie auf und dann kommt dann so eine Auswahl, dass du ein Stereo- und ein Multi-Channel-Setup irgendwie machen kannst. So mit so Surround und Quadrophonik und welchen Quatsch nicht alles. Du weißt überhaupt gar nicht, was Sache ist. Aber tatsächlich handelt es sich dabei einfach um die Default-Kanäle. Also wenn ein Programm einfach so das Device aufmacht und hier hast du Stereo, dann kannst du hier tatsächlich mappen, auf welchen Kanal das geht. Und damit könnte ich mir dann zum Beispiel so ein virtuelles Device machen, so ein Aggregate Device. Das nenne ich halt einfach irgendwie Soundboard. So, da schmeiße ich dann irgendwie mein 16-Kanal-Interface rein. Und da sage ich dann, dass meine Kanäle 1, 2 halt irgendwo sind. Und damit kann man das irgendwie regeln.
Das heißt, man kann sich da so ein Aggregate Device reinmachen, da könnte ich mein Audio-Interface mit den 6, 8 Kanälen reintun und dann könnte ich Skype sagen, benutze mal hier meinen Fubo Ho Chi Minh Flower Power Enterprises Virtual Aggregated Device.
Geht aber nur Output und nicht Input.
Achso, das ist ja auch Configure Speakers, nicht Microphones.
Ja, es könnte so schön sein, wenn Apple das kleine Ding dann auch noch einbauen würde, wäre das Problem schon gegessen. Dann kannst du ja einfach virtuelle Sound-Devices für alles anlegen und alles wäre super. Geht aber nicht, wegen Bodennebel. Dass dieser Mac nicht in der Lage ist, einem mal so einen Mixer vor die Nase zu werfen. Und wo man auch mal sieht, was passiert. Das ist ja auch so ein Problem. Bei jedem guten Mischpult hast du so Pegel. Und dann siehst du, dass da was zuppelt.
Selbst bei Windows hast du so einen Mixer.
Ja, selbst bei Windows.
Noch schlechter als Apple.
Nee, besser in dem Fall.
Ja, selbst die.
Ich meine, ich verstehe, dass das wahrscheinlich bei Windows auch absolut erforderlich war, solche Subsysteme zu bauen, um den ganzen Kack überhaupt laufen zu bekommen. Ich erinnere so an die damalige Zeit, wo man so in PCs noch Jumper setzen musste, um irgendwie Karten an die richtige Stelle konfiguriert zu bekommen und so. Da kommt dann wahrscheinlich das Essen hoch. Viele von diesen Diagnose-Dingern, die auf dem Mac so nie nötig waren, sind wahrscheinlich aus so einer Kultur heraus auch entstanden. Aber wie auch immer. Totally alle Credits an Microsoft dafür, dass sie sowas machen.
Bei dem Linux müssen die im Club auch andauernd den Lautstärkeregler an 1000 verschiedenen Stellen suchen, wo jetzt wieder was leise ist.
Ehrlich, Linux und Audio und Video, das ist verloren. Das ist einfach vergebliche mit Liebesmüh.
Das wird nix.
Die haben ja noch nicht mal da irgendwie ein einheitliches irgendwas, worauf sie sich in irgendeiner Form gehandigt haben.
Na doch, nur jedes Jahr ein neues.
Also klar, wenn man sich da super auskennt und so, dann kann man sich das alles wunderbar zusammenkoppeln. Ja, dafür ist es ja auch gemacht. Also ich erkenne das vollständig an. Linux ist eine super Basis, um sich seine eigenen Systeme zu bauen. Und Windows und Mac sind halt fertige Systeme. Das hat beides seine Berechtigungen, das hat beides seine... Aber man will halt eigentlich ein fertiges System haben, was dann maximal zuverlässig arbeitet, aber so flexibel wie nötig. Und ich finde, dass der Mac da ganz gut positioniert ist an sich. Also es ist ein fertiges System, was ziemlich fette Aussagen darüber macht, wie eigentlich alles zusammengesteckt sein muss, sollte. Also wie es gedacht ist. So wie es gedacht ist, funktioniert es auch gut. Die Frage ist nur, wie weit kann man dieses System dazu bringen, mal auch ab und zu mal in eine andere Richtung zu denken, außer nur der, was sie sich von Anfang an so über ihr System gedacht haben. Anpassungsfähigkeiten und so weiter. Und bei Liduns kannst du natürlich alles Mögliche anpassen. Musst es aber dann meistens aber auch tun, weil es halt keine so gedachte Welt gibt, in die sich alles erstmal so hineinfallen lassen kann. Aber vorher, wie der Flamewall losgeht, so ist es auch gedacht. Und so hat es auch seine Richtigkeit. Und es ist halt auch sehr schwierig, glaube ich, in dieser Audio-Welt mit diesen hohen Anforderungen an Realtime und so weiter zu bestehen. Und dazu natürlich auch mit Firmen, die sich selbstverständlich dann an die gemachten Systeme stürzen, weil sie da natürlich ihre Software sehr viel besser platzieren können und sich natürlich dann nicht die Mühe machen, jetzt noch ihre Hardware mit Linux durchzutesten oder geschweige denn da vielleicht zuverlässige Treiber bereitzustellen. Das ist halt alles so ein Problem. Ja, da endet dann mein Teil 2 an der Stelle. Also man kann ja einen Teilaspekt irgendwie lösen, aber so richtig geil ist es nicht. Und man braucht einfach mal einen Mixer. Apple, wirklich. Also einfach so ein Ding. Ich meine, alles Mögliche kann man da monitoren. Ja, jeden Scheiß-System-Call kannst du da in Echtzeit runterrattern und durchmonitoren. Aber es gibt keinen View, wo ich mir mal den Zustand des Audiosystems anschauen kann. Welche Kanäle sind offen? Welche Programme schreiben auf welche Devices? Ich will einfach eine Pegel-Anzeige haben. Ich will einfach sehen, dass da was kommt. Und ich will es vielleicht an der Stelle auch abgreifen und aufnehmen können. Aber das ist vielleicht dann auch an der Stelle mir dann ein Problem. Weil aufnehmen, was Programme ausgeben und so, das könnte ja unserer DAM-Scheiße dann irgendwie abgreifen und so. Dass es trotzdem funktioniert mit Audio Hijack Pro, sehen wir ja. Aber ich glaube gar nicht, dass das so eine große Verschwörung ist. Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur mangelnde Ressourcen und mangelnde Prioritäten. Oder einfach nicht meine Prioritäten.
Ja, wobei, also ich meine, ich sitze ja auch da, wenn ich jetzt diesen anderen Podcast da bei mir aufnehme. Und das machen wir jetzt ja auch über Skype. Wobei der andere auch seine Tonspur dann noch mal zu Hause aufnimmt und mir dann uploadet, sodass wir dann schon die ordentlichen Audi-Spuren zusammenmixen und nicht das ganze.
Ich sage es, Double Ender. Ja, an beiden Enden aufgenommen. Double Ender.
So und jetzt, wenn man aber über Skype, wenn ich irgendwas einspielen will, dass dann irgendwie das totale Hexenwerk, ein Sound aus dem Quicktime jetzt irgendwo da reinzuschicken, das System wieder an Skype rauszugeben. Also klar, ich kann irgendwie Mixes machen und so weiter und so fort, aber dass diese Mixes dann wieder im Skype landen und alles. Also selbst bei den simpelsten Anforderungen scheitert es ja. Also die simpelsten Anforderungen, die darüber hinausgehen, Spotify abzuspielen oder sowas. Und das ist eigentlich schon... Also du musst halt immer so komische Third-Party-Software benutzen, die dann irgendwie auch nur so halb irgendwie geht. Und naja, irgendwie fühlt sich das schon eher so an, als könnte das das OS ruhig mal machen. Aber ja, der Roddy hat ja auch schon oft genug über das Chor-Audio gelästert. Vielleicht ist auch einfach alles ganz all und stinkt aus dem Mund. Und jeder, der sich das dann so ein bisschen näher anguckt, der denkt dann vielleicht, ich kümmere mich mal um was anderes. Na ja, so ist es halt.
Doch, was haben wir noch?
Eigentlich nichts.
Kongress.
Ah, stimmt.
Da war noch was.
Wir gehen alle auf den Kongress.
Naja, aber der Kongress fällt ja dieses Jahr aus, weil wir machen ja Party eigentlich.
Echt?
Ja, ich glaube ja, es wird der Party-Kongress.
Das wird der Party-Kongress? Weil kein Camp ist dieses Jahr, oder?
Nächstes Jahr auch nicht.
Es ist der 30.?!
Was ist der 30. Deswegen fällt er aus?
Nee, deswegen ist es der Party. Und es ist auch ein bisschen vergrößert diesmal. Weil es war letztes Jahr schon ganz schön groß, aber es war nicht groß genug.
Das ist wirklich absurd, oder?
Es wird nicht groß genug sein dieses Jahr, hoffe ich.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Dass da noch mehr Leute kommen?
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man mit dem Platzangebot, das dieses Jahr herrscht, irgendwie an seine Grenzen kommt. Aber ich hab ja schon so einiges nicht vorstellen können bei dem Kongress.
Und es wird auf jeden Fall cool werden.
Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zu den Dimensionen. Also im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr, manche waren ja vielleicht da. Wer überhaupt noch keine Ahnung hat, wovon wir reden, wir reden vom 30. Chaos Communication Kongress am Ende dieses Jahres in Hamburg im CCH.
bis 30. oder 12.
Eine Veranstaltung, die in der Kategorie highly anticipated ist. Ich hab das auch schon lange nicht mehr so intensiv erlebt, dass so viel in der Luft schwirrt. Nach diesem krassen Jahr. Und nach der Vorlage im letzten Jahr könnte das Timing kaum besser sein. Und letztes Jahr gab es einen Saal, wo 3000 Leute reinpassen. Dann gab es einen zweiten, wo 800 Leute reinpassen, offiziell. Und einen, wo glaube ich 400 Leute reinpassen. Dies Jahr gibt es einen Saal, der wieder 3000er. Der zweite hat 1500 Leute. Und der dritte fast, weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich glaube auch 1000. So in der Größenordnung.
In 800 haben wir gar nicht mehr.
Doch, aber da ist Catering. Dazu kommt nochmal ein Saal, wo im Prinzip 1000 Leute reinpassen würden, bloß der kein Vortragssaal ist, sondern das ist halt diese Assembly-Zone, die neu ist. Also es kommen drei Räume dazu, die so in ihrer Gesamtausdehnung ungefähr der Hälfte des größten Raums entsprechen. Auch wenn die alle sehr architektonisch, sehr unterschiedlich sind. Aber es sind einfach drei riesige Flächen. Der Saal 2 wiederum auch im selben Style wie Saal 1, halb bloß halb so groß.
Deswegen verschwindet aber auch ein bisschen Platz auf den Fluren, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab. Weil durch die neuen Räume da die Gänge freigehalten werden müssen. Früher war ja auch viel in den Gängen. Das ist jetzt nicht mehr erlaubt, weil die Gänge halt gebraucht werden. Deswegen ist halt Catering wahrscheinlich auch an diesen einen Saal da gegangen.
Ja, aber auch weil das Catering, glaube ich, da an diesem, also man hätte das theoretisch da auch wieder tun können, wo es gemacht wurde, aber ich fand das total elend. Also das war eigentlich eher einer der, weil da gab es keine Tische, auch aus denselben Gründen, weil das halt in diesem Fluchtbereich war.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine CC Mensa, ja?
Jetzt gibt es da mehr so ein Dining Room. Wie der da genau aussehen wird, weiß ich nicht, aber da ist dann auf jeden Fall Platz. Das heißt, es wird auch kommunikativer, man kann sich beim Essen treffen, unterhalten und letztes Mal war das eher so ein bisschen so eine Durchlaufstelle und ich hoffe auch, dass das Essen etwas länger verfügbar sein wird. Aber das werden sie sicherlich selber gemerkt haben letztes Jahr. Ja, dann was kommt noch dazu? Dann kommt noch ein vierter Vortragstrack, der ist dann wieder in diesem kleinen Raum, der letztes Mal der dritte Track war. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da so ein Fan bin, zu viele Tracks zu haben.
Parallel dann halt, das heißt, es sind vier Tracks parallel, oder?
Erstens sind sie halt parallel und zweitens weiß ich auch nicht, ob das reine quantitative Aufbläden von Veranstaltungen diesen immer so gerecht wird.
Mir ist egal, vorher habe ich drei verpasst pro jetzt und dann werde ich jetzt halt vier verpassen pro jetzt.
Ja gut, aber du weißt ja, dass andere Leute diese Veranstaltung etwas anders wahrnehmen als du.
Ja, aber die verpassen auch immer mindestens zwei und müssen eh eine Menge auf Videos nachgucken.
Es geht mir weniger um das Verpassen, weil das ist eh normal, sondern es geht mir um dieses, wenn du so eine Veranstaltung hast, dann steigt ja der Wert der Vorträge auch dadurch, dass sie durch einen Auswahlprozess zustande gekommen sind. Oder diesen haben erstmal passieren müssen. Sprich, du gehst davon aus, dass das, was dort präsentiert wird, gewissen Qualitätsanforderungen entspricht. Ob man das immer als Qualitätsanforderungen definieren möchte, aber zumindest musste es eine bestimmte Hürde übernehmen. Umso mehr du anbietest, umso beliebiger wird das. Ist einfach so.
Du meinst, mit vier Tracks parallel sinkt die Quality?
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das so sein wird. Vielleicht werden danach auch alle schreien, wie geil, sogar im vierten Track bin ich noch so gehirnfickt worden wie noch nie. Ja, kann ja alles sein, aber ich sag nur, die Wahrnehmung ist schwierig. Der Kongress hätte nur einen einzigen Track, dann ist die Bedeutung, die auf so einem Vortrag liegt, enorm, weil das ist der Vortrag, der jetzt gerade ist und es gibt keinen anderen. Bei zweien hast du das in etwa noch so. Drei ist schon das Abfeiern eines breiten Programms. Das wird mit vier und fünf und sechs Tracks dann...
Vier ist dann schon RTL, meinst du?
Ja, ich meine die Republika hatte glaube ich letztes Jahr sechs oder sieben Tracks parallel. Da weißt du dann überhaupt nicht mehr, was irgendwie wichtig sein soll.
Ja, sag ich ja. Die mehreren Sender waren auch der Untergang der Fernsehkultur, weil man kann sich gar nicht mehr unterhalten, weil jeder hat die nächsten Tage, wenn ich unterhalten wollte, hat was anderes gesehen.
Genau, das ist dann auch so dieses Agenda-Setting so. Was ist denn das Thema eigentlich, auf das man sich jetzt einlassen soll? Es ist immer so, ja, hast du den Vortrag gesehen? Ja, nee, ich war bei dem anderen. Oder vielleicht auch bei Kalben, was immer passieren kann. Aber auch da denke ich, ist es halt, man bereitet sich auf das Programm umso mehr vor, umso geringer die Auswahl ist. Es gibt natürlich so Nerds, die dann alles durcharbeiten und so.
Es ist halt so erste Liga, zweite Liga, dritte Liga und dann Regionalliga Nord.
Also ich will gar nichts schlecht machen und es kann auch alles anders sein. Ich sag nur, ich war da etwas skeptisch. Jetzt kann man das nehmen. Es werden sicherlich auch eine Menge andere Sachen stattfinden. Dann gibt es eine Abschlussparty, die nicht weit weg ist, sondern vor Ort stattfindet. Also in der Lounge, es gibt überhaupt erst mal die Lounge. Die zieht in diese Halle. Und es gibt halt auch nur eine Lounge und nicht zwei wie letztes Mal. Das fand ich auch ein bisschen bekloppt. Du hast dieses oben und dann gab es da unten noch dieses ganze Wochenzelt.
Ich hab gehört, ein Grund war, weil das war dem Hotel da ein bisschen zu laut.
Ja, das war auch einfach zu kalt und das war auch einfach zu bekloppt.
Ja, kalt wird es in der Halle jetzt auch. Ich meine, die kriegst du schon wärmer, aber warm ist da jetzt drin auch nicht. Diese Halle heizt du mal nicht so eben schnell, oder?
Naja, die ist auf jeden Fall deutlich besser isoliert als so ein Zelt.
Naja, kann es nicht durch wehen und so, das ist schon richtig, aber...
Das werden wir sehen.
Kannst da nicht ein T-Shirt rumrennen, glaube ich. Kommt auf die Größe, ich weiß nicht, was die da aufbauen, aber es wird auf jeden Fall besser werden, vor allem kann man mehr krach machen. Und jeder, der nicht kommt, da sag ich nur selber Schuld und Tochius oder nach.
Ich fahr dies ja auch hin. Ich war allen einzigen Kongress in 12 oder 13 Jahren nicht da.
Den Letzten.
Das kann man wohl mal verzeihen.
Ach, den Letzten hast du verpasst.
Die Jahre davor kam er auch nur kurz mal vorbei, weil sein Kassen-System, da hat man kurz mal rüber geguckt, irgendwelche Rubis neu gestartet und dann ist er wieder abgezogen. Und dann doch erst am letzten Tag oder so.
Ja, doch, doch.
Die haben nicht vermisst.
Diesmal fahr ich nach Hamburg und hab auch Hotel für alle vier Tage, quasi.
Ich hab Buchort.
Aber scheiße, wenn da ein Abschlussparty ist, müssen die eigentlich noch einen Tag länger bleiben.
Wann ist denn die?
Am Schluss.
Am 30. Abends? Wirklich, wenn alle abbauen müssen, das Party?
Besser, als wenn die Party 5 km entfernt ist. Da kannst du nämlich keinen mehr irgendwie rausziehen.
Währenddessen, dann irgendwie vorletzter Tag, Nacht um 12 und dann geht's ab. Okay, dann kann nächsten Tag auch keiner abbauen.
Da kommt nämlich keiner.
Weil alle in der Halle irgendwo breit am Boden liegen.
Ja, ich meine, das ist ja eh alles durchgehend Party da.
Ja, das meine ich. Deswegen Abschlussparty.
Kommen wir nochmal zu den sonstigen Features. Also was sehr betont werden wird, noch im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr, sind halt diese Assemblies. Das war ja im Prinzip so die große Neuerung beim 29C3. Also überhaupt, dass man diesen Begriff aufgerufen hat. Früher gab es halt mal die Villages im Hackcenter. Das war eigentlich so ein ähnliches Ding. Oder haben wir das überhaupt so genannt? Am Camp haben wir das so genannt mit den Villages. Aber beim... Ich weiß es jetzt gar nicht mehr. Naja, im Wesentlichen heißt es nichts anderes, als man hat da so ein Projekt und alle Leute, die diesem Projekt sich zugehörig fühlen und beieinander hocken wollen, die gründen da so eine Assemblis und eine Zusammenkunft. Und das TCH war ja letztes Mal gefühlt schon ja gut aufgeladen mit solchen Assemblis. Also es gab Derafile und überall. Und man hatte das Gefühl, wenn man rumläuft, man tritt sich Hecker ein. Und da war das halt jetzt auch sehr verteilt über diese Flure. Da muss man nochmal gucken, ob das jetzt wirklich so langweilig wird, dadurch, dass da diese Feuerschutzmaßnahmen berücksichtigt werden müssen. Aber dafür gibt es halt diesen großen Assembly-Saal 3. Wenn man auf CCH guckt, das ist so ein ganz basicer, großer, viereckiger hoher Raum, wo oben so Lichtstrahler in Massen angebracht sind. Mit Holz. Parkett.
Plattee-Füllung.
Ja, aber da kann man gut tanzen. Und da wird so ein bisschen das... Also im Prinzip ist das auch die Wiedergeburt des Hack-Centers, weil das hat es letztes Jahr eigentlich so nicht gegeben, aber irgendwie alles Hack-Center. Und jetzt gibt es halt mal wieder so eine richtige Zentrale, wo sich das alles ein wenig findet. Aber eben auch an anderen Ebenen. Also es gibt dieses Zentrum, aber es gibt auch sehr viele andere Bereiche, wohin sich das alles noch ausdehnen kann. Ja, und jetzt gibt es im Wiki da allerlei Allerlei Assemblies, die sich angemeldet haben. Ich muss mir ja gleich nach der Sendung auch noch mal einen kleinen Eintrag vornehmen, denn wir werden dann auch mal vertreten sein mit einer Assemblie.
Wer sind wir?
Wir ist Podlove. Das kleine Podcasting-Universum wird dort vor Ort sein. Und ich hoffe, dass möglichst viele auch so aus der Developer-Kurve da aufschlagen werden. Also einige sind definitiv da. Und natürlich sehen wir das gerne, wenn andere, die da Interesse haben, irgendwie anzudocken dieses Tun und dann vielleicht sich auch erwärmen lassen, bei dem einen oder anderen Experiment- und Forschungseinheit mal vielleicht dazu zu stoßen. Parallel dazu werden wir dieses Sendezentrum wieder machen, was wir auf der Republika das erste Mal gemacht haben. Also hier mit Ralf und Claudia von den Wikigeeks plus noch einigen anderen, die da mithelfen werden. Das Team findet sich jetzt gerade. Wollen wir dann halt einmal am Tag auch eine Radiosendung machen. Und wir werden auch Podcastern die Gelegenheit geben, dort die Infrastruktur mitzunutzen. Das heißt, wenn man vor Ort einen Podcast aufnehmen möchte mit vier, fünf, sechs Leuten maximal, hat aber keinen Bock dieses ganze Equipment mitzuschleppen.
Und hat auf jeden Fall Bock auf Knistern im Audio-Kanal.
Also es gibt kostenlos dazu.
Im Kino zahlen die Leute noch für ihre Popcorn-Tüte. Hier gibt es das einfach obendrein. Also der Plan ist so ein Tisch, also ob der Plan dann so auch exekutiert wird, das wird sich zeigen, aber danach sieht es jetzt gerade aus. Es wird halt so einen runden Tisch geben, hoffe ich, an dem so Recording-Equipment quasi festgetackert ist mit Headsets und allem und man kann sich dann voranmelden und sagen, ja hier Tag 3, keine Ahnung, 14 Uhr, wollen wir da eine Stunde rum sitzen und dann kann man da irgendwie aufschlagen, sich hinsetzen, eine SD-Karte reinstecken, auf Rekord drücken und los geht's. So. Und dann ist man fertig, dann drückt man auf Stop, zieht die SD-Karte wieder raus, hat seinen Podcast in den Fingern und kann wieder der Wege gehen. Das ist so Instant-Gruppen-Podcasting. Ohne Live, wer das live machen will, muss noch da ein Mini-Klinkenkabel rausziehen. Muss noch eine Bitcoin einwerfen, genau. Also wer ein Streaming-Setup auf seinem Rechner hat, kann es damit dann auch gerne selber machen, aber das muss eben in eigener Zuständigkeit geschehen. Üblicherweise wollen die Leute ja dann auch ihre eigenen Streaming-Entitäten kontaktieren und brauchen eh das ganze Login-Setup, etc., Es wird also Miniklinke geben, die steckt man rein, dann kann man das damit machen. Netz wird ja wahrscheinlich sehr zuverlässig sein auf dem Kongress. Ich glaube, davon kann man ausgehen. Und auf der Live-Bühne machen wir dann halt einmal am Tag die Sendung und vielleicht nehmen wir, wer da Interesse hätte, da was zu machen, da sind wir aber ein bisschen wählerischer. Geben wir noch ein oder zwei Slots pro Tag frei, wo man da auch vielleicht so ein Public-Radio machen kann. Und du, Dennis, machst Kasse. Wie immer. Da hast du dich ganz schön reingefressen in das Thema.
Ja, ich wurde als Zwangsverpflichtet.
Schon wieder?
Nee, damals. Dann hab ich da so reingewachsen. Ich hab ja früher irgendwie Netzwerke gemacht, das machen ja jetzt Jungs, die das auch als Job haben. Da kann ich ja gar nicht mithalten. Ich hab halt früher da Switches hingeschmissen und Kabel verlegt. Heute geht es ja ein bisschen anders. Wobei die immer noch Switches schmeißen und Kabel verlegen, aber noch ein bisschen mehr machen. Und das hab ich irgendwie nicht mehr gemacht. Dann war ich so ein bisschen arbeitslos auf dem Kongress und meinte, wie kann ich mich so einbringen? Weil Kongress ohne was zu tun, das ist mir ganz langweilig. Also weil ich nur Vorträge gucke, das ist mir den Arsch breit.
Das kenn ich auch, das Gefühl. Also nur an so einer Veranstaltung teilnehmen, das geht gar nicht.
Also das ist vielleicht auch mal cool, so vor ein paar Stunden, so ein bisschen rumlaufen, so ohne alles, aber ich brauche auch irgendwie was zu tun, sonst ist mir es auch teilweise zu viel, ich brauche da eine Sache, auf wo ich meinen Fokus drauf richten kann, sonst kriege ich da Information-Overflow. Und dann habe ich gesagt, na hier Jungs, ich hab früher schon mal Kasse gemacht, hab mal an einer Tankstelle gejobbt und so und wie gesagt, ich mach mal Kasse bei euch, die Trantüten da vorne. An der größten Berlins. Da war der Polenmarkt noch, da ging es ab.
Welche war denn das?
Reichspiegel-Ufer, da wo jetzt Daimler draufsteht, die gibt es nicht mehr. So eine Shell war das. Direkt neben dem Polenmarkt. Kannst dir vorstellen, was da am Wochenende los war. Da saß Dennis an der Kasse, hat alles gemanagt. Und das geht ja ein bisschen langsam. Lange Schlangen kennst du ja so bis raus und die Leute frieren und so. Ich mach Kasse und arbeite euch das alles weg. Und dann wollte ich da machen und hab ich auch einmal gemacht. Und dann glaube ich, kam Starbucks an und meinte, was Dennis, du da vorne? Nee, nix da, Alter. Du machst hier hinten und so die dicken Scheine. Und seitdem bin ich halt im Hinterzimmer gelandet. Dabei macht mir Kasse vorne fast mehr Spaß.
Machste aber auch Front oder nicht?
Ja, wenn wir die wieder zu schnarchnasig sind. So eine Nachtschicht zum Beispiel, da sitze ich im Hinterzimmer, dann vorne sitzt ein Kassensupervisor, und daneben sitzt einer, der die Kasse macht. Dann sag ich, Jungs, ihr könnt alle gehen. Ich mach das alleine und superweise mich alleine und geb mir später mein Geld alleine. Dann kann ich das alles da selber regeln. Dann muss ich da nicht irgendwie Leute haben, die Leute haben, die Leute machen lassen.
Ich verstehe, du weißt einfach...
Nur nachts ist das aber.
You're getting rid of the middle management.
Das sowieso, Katze-Middle-Man heißt es.
Du bist ja sozusagen ein Mann Apple bist du ja dann. Na ja, die haben ja auch Lean-Management und wenig Hierarchie.
Ich bin die One-Man-Show.
Die One-Man-Show.
Kassen One-Man-Show.
Ja, aber Huckel hier war ja früher auch Kasse. Hat ja immer unser Kassen-Backend gekodet in Ruby. Ist immer noch lustig. Manchmal zu lustig und dann muss man mal...
Soll ich euch was sagen? Ich beneide euch.
Warum?
Weil ich auch Bock drauf hätte, mal wieder sowas zu machen. Aber ich bin da irgendwie rausgewachsen, bevor ich da je reingewachsen bin.
Na, du hast doch die ganze Show mal geschwitzt.
Ja, aber da bin ich auch irgendwie mehr oder weniger von 0 auf 100 gelandet. Also ich hab mich nicht vom Tellerwäscher hochgearbeitet.
Du konntest dich nicht von der Couch hochschlafen.
Nee, das war ja ein Unfall, dass ich irgendwie Kongress-Orga gemacht hab.
Ja, mit der Kasse war auch ein Unfall. Starbuck ist schuld.
Ja, sowas passiert dann halt so, ne? Aber wenn du dann gleich irgendwie mit so die Stelle...
Ja, aber wie viele Leute kamen zu deinem ersten Kongress?
2500.
Gleich so viele? Beim ersten? In Berlin?
Ja. Echt?
Haben wir gleich mit so viel angefangen? 98? Da hab ich angefangen mit Switcher schmeißen und verteilen. Da hab ich bei Pixelpark ein paar alte Switcher eingesammelt, die gut genug waren. Kabel und so. Und dann hab ich die da...
Der Kongress hat sich da vergefühlt, also keiner weiß genau die Zahlen vorher, aber das ist ungefähr so eine Verdrei- bis Vervierfachung der Teilnehmerzahl gewesen. Dadurch, dass das Ding nach Berlin gegangen ist. Genau, von Hamburg. Ich mein, der ist irgendwie Hamburg-Eidlstedt. Ja, also das ist ungefähr so, als ob du in Berlin... Ich warte mal.... in Spandau den Kongress machen würdest. Oder Friedenau oder... Außerhalb.
Ja. Kürpenig.
Marzahn.
Ich mein gerade einer ganz kurz, die Tanke gibt's nicht mehr. Pixelpark ist auch weg. Den Kongress gibt's noch.
Den Kongress gibt's noch. So genau.
Und dann ist er irgendwie nach Berlin gekommen. Und dann war er halt, glaube ich, allein schon, weil er in Berlin war, schon mal doppelt und dreimal so. Also da gab's einfach ein ganz anderes Ding. Das war das Einzugsgebiet. Ich meine, die Zeit war reif. Es war Internet, es hat sich auch schon abgezeichnet bei dem 14. Kongress. Also der letzte in Hamburg war ja gegenüber dem Vorgänger auch doppelt so besetzt. Also normalerweise muss man sich mal vorstellen, auf dem Kongress waren vielleicht so 300 Gestalten.
Wir reden jetzt von...
Wir reden von bis 1996.
Mitte bis 97, ja. Genau, 97 war der letzte in Hamburg damals.
Genau, so 1994, 95 und so. Mitte der 90er Jahre waren da 300 Leute. Oder vielleicht waren es 400 Leute. Ich kenne die Zahlen nicht genau, aber ich kenne ja... Du kennst doch den Ort. Was war da? Ich meine, der größte Saal fast 200 Leute. Und dann gibt es halt noch so ein paar kleine Räume. Also da war nicht viel Raum. Und dann kamen sie auf einmal alle mit ihren Desktop-Tower an, mit Turbotasse, und standen da im Flur mit ihren 20 Zoll CRTs und dicken, fetten Keyboards mit Nummerntaste und so weiter.
So war es ja.
Laptops hatte keiner. Aber jeder brachte seine komplette Weihnachtsausrüstung PC mit. Diese, gerade so schön von Papa und Mama, haben irgendwie unter den Baum legen lassen. Und dann haben sie es gleich weiter geschleppt nach Eidelstedt.
So geil, jetzt mit dem Equipment und mit Modem.
Jetzt auch mit Internet.
Genau, jetzt vielleicht auch mit Internet. Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Internetversorgung damals war. Es gab Internet. Aber so, dass das so an jedem Rechner durchgerootet wurde, weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau. Schon so lange her. Aber die Vergrößerung war halt einfach enorm. Der Schritt nach Hamburg war jetzt ähnlich.
Ja, nicht ganz. Hat sich ja nicht verdreifacht.
Nö, aber es hat sich verdoppelt und das ist schon... Na gut, jetzt ist die Frage, was wir als die offizielle Zahl der Teilnehmer sehen.
Also 3000 waren da schon locker in Berlin am Ende, oder?
Ja, natürlich mehr.
Ja, und wie viel hatten wir jetzt in Hamburg?
Sieben.
Ich stehe. Ja, ich hab ja keinen Durchblick da, ich kassiere nur.
Wie viele Tickets da rausgehen mit, egal.
Ich nehme halt die bunten Scheine und leg die da irgendwo hin.
Das sieht man ja nicht so richtig, weil es ja auch eine Menge prepaid und so. Also das kann man alles gar nicht mehr so.
Genau, also es war irgendwie so zwischen sechs und sechs.
Also in meinem Kassensystem hat man auch gesehen, wie viele prepaid Tickets.
Ja, hätte ich da vielleicht gucken können, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Auch wenn ich es jetzt wüsste, dürfte ich die Zahl ja eh nicht nennen.
Wobei die Zahl ist jetzt Headcount, also sozusagen mit Tagestickets und so weiter. Nicht Dauergäste und so weiter, das relativiert sich ja auch alles wieder. Aber Tatsache ist, dass der Zuspruch war enorm. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir denn jetzt darauf gekommen sind.
Wir haben vom Kongress gesprochen.
Ja, wir haben vom Kongress gesprochen.
Du hast gesagt, du willst auch mal wieder und haben gesagt, dass du das auch mal gemacht hast.
Genau.
Tim hat nämlich, um es nochmal deutlich zu sagen, den Kongress von Hamburg nach Berlin geholt. Und hier auch gemanagt, geschmissen. Wann hast du aufgehört hier in Berlin? 2008, 2009?
Ich hab so mit dem... 23, das ist ein bisschen ausgelaufen, aber der 25 C3 war der erste, wo ich eigentlich gar nichts mehr getan hab.
Echt? So früh schon?
Oder der 26.
Ach so, zwischendurch hatten ja Maljulia und Erfar irgendwie einmal gemacht, ne?
Ja, also...
Und Art hat mal irgendwann mit reingeholt, so ein bisschen?
Ja, es gab immer viele Leute, die mal wirklich viel Zeit investiert haben. Fukami, Artord, Tom, Lazar. Es gab immer mal wieder so Main Assistants, Henriette, ganz lang. Und mit Julia begann dann so ein bisschen die zweite Ära. Also der Kongress hat sich ja mit dem 21C3 eigentlich komplett neu erfunden. Also bis zum 21C3 einschließlich war das so im Prinzip so unser alter Kongress in groß. Aber genauso muckelig durcheinander verspult, chaotisch wie schon immer. So und das rechte sich so ein bisschen nach dem in dem Jahr. 20C3 war ja der erste im BCC. Nach dem Umzug des Gebäudes und unmittelbar nach dem zweiten Camp. Das war eine Kombination, die ging gar nicht.
Welche Jahr wartet?
Na, 2003. Weil die selbe Truppe machte sozusagen das Camp und war dann noch im Oktober komplett gerädert und dann zwei Monate später Kongress. Für mich war das unbefriedigend.
Also die Leute, die sich vielleicht nicht so vorstellen kann und man selber kann sich das eigentlich auch nie vorstellen, weil wahrscheinlich keiner das im Komplettbild so wirklich sehen kann, nicht mal wahrscheinlich der C-Punkt, der das gerade macht, von ganz oben, wie viel Action da gerade passiert, um diesen Kongress zu machen. Also es ist ja nicht nur das Top-Management, was da gerade voll am Rudern ist, schon seit Wochen und Monaten, sondern ja auch die ganzen Unter-Airfers, die da ihre Projekte vorbereiten, machen, tun. Ich will von Berlin aus dieses Display, was wir da an der Wand haben, machen wir gerade schick, um das auch zum Kongress zu kriegen und so. Also überall sind Leute da machen und tun. Seidenstraße ist gerade am Start, müsst ihr mal googeln, wenn ihr das noch nicht kennt. Also es ist ein riesen Alarm, der da gerade stattfindet. Und das ist eigentlich schon auch jedes Jahr so.
Wobei das hier, das hat sich auch in den letzten Jahren wirklich enorm gesteigert. Also das so aus, also diese enorme, dieses enorme Hinarbeiten auf den Kongress durch alle möglichen Teilnehmer, das ist so über die Zeit wirklich angewachsen.
Ja, naja, wenn man sich drauf verlassen kann, dass der stattfindet und auf seinen Space verlassen kann und dass Platz da ist und...
Man ein Ticket kriegt...
.dass andere Leute auch alle hinfahren und so, dass es ja auch wieder ein gesehen werden und Leute treffen.
Das kommt nämlich dieses Jahr, glaube ich, das erste Mal zusammen. Also diesmal ist wirklich klar, es gibt Platz ohne Ende. Man muss keine Angst haben, dass man da reinkommt.
Es gibt Tickets.
So, das war lange, lange, lange Zeit jetzt im BCC so ein Thema. Und das ist jetzt vorbei.
Also was jetzt noch fehlt, ist eigentlich Fahrradverleih im BCC.
CCH.
CCH, whatever. Damit man da schneller vorwärtskommt. Weil man muss da sonst latschener bis zum Abdenken. Hast du das mit den Segways erzählt? Das gibt es neue Segways mit nur einem Rad.
Ja, letztens in Schöneberg stehe ich da so und warte auf einen Taxi, glaube ich. Und sehe irgendwie so einen Typen, also so ein Asiater, steht so irgendwie in der Gegend rum, guckt auf ein Smartphone und bewegt sich so. Ich habe seine Füße noch nicht so gesehen, aber es war irgendwie nichts dran und so. Dann kam er so vorbei und dachte mir, okay, jetzt ist hier gleich die Hecke vorbei. Mal gucken, worauf der da so gerade rumrollt. Dann stand er so auf so einem Einrad Segway quasi und hat irgendwie gar nicht auf die Straße geguckt, sondern hat auf sein PDA geguckt. Dann kam so ein paar Rentner entgegen und ich so, okay, checkt ihr das? Dann hat er so kurz hoch geguckt und hat so einen ganz galanten Schlenker einfach so um die Weite, hat weiter auf sein PDA geguckt oder auf sein Smartphone und ist weitergerollt. Ganz silky smooth und das heißt, warte, ich such's mal gerade raus, ich glaube Mono, Mono Wheel oder so. Also es gibt zwei, eine schwedische Firma und eine amerikanische. Ah Gott, wie war denn das? Also wenn man irgendwie muss so gucken nach...
Nee, das ist es nicht.
Das ist es nicht. Nee, nee, wie hieß denn das? Ah verdammt Single Wheel, Mono Wheel. Ah, warte...
Segway One Wheel kannst du ja mal probieren. Vielleicht kommt ja dann irgendwas.
Jaja, genau, irgendwie.
Solo Wheel.
Solo Wheel, okay.
Das ist das eine, genau. Und dann gibt's irgendwie, also eins ist schwedisch, eins ist amerikanisch, die einen kann man kaufen, die anderen noch nicht.
Ach, das ist nur ein Rad.
Das ist nur ein Rad.
Nur ein Rad mit links und rechts, wo man draufstehen kann.
Guck dir mal die Videos da.
Segway, die ärgern sich so doll, glaube ich, jetzt. Wenn es wirklich cool ist.
Guck mal, Solo Wheel in Action.
Will ich auch sehen, will ich auch sehen. Alle mal klicken, Jungs.
solowheel.com, da ist die Webseite.
Großfach geht gar nicht in der Zeit.
Kannst du auf YouTube suchen nochmal.
Aber jetzt den Sound dazu anzumachen, ist wahrscheinlich unangemessen, oder?
Im Chat ist schon der Link. Den macht den anderen aus, den Mauslern. Ja genau, müsste das sein, außer er treut uns jetzt. Ne, MonoWheel, the Art of Moving. Den anderen kannst du ausmachen.
Das ist jetzt MonoWheel, das ist wieder der andere Hersteller. Es gibt halt SoloWheel und MonoWheel.
Achso, aber das funktioniert ja genau so.
Ja genau, die sehen auch total gleich aus. Aber die einen sind aus Amerika, die anderen aus Schweden. Bei den einen kannst du es kaufen, bei den anderen noch nicht.
Wieso fällt das nicht um?
Weil da, wo du drauf trittst, ist es halt tiefer als der Rest. Also als die Achse. Das heißt, dadurch stabilisiert es sich schon mal. Links und rechts musst du wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ausgleichen. Und das Ding rollt halt und dadurch wird es stabil auch.
Das ist halt auch total wendig. Der Typ ist total selbstsicher.
Mit Kinderwagen.
Hammer.
Dabei könnte die Batterie eigentlich im Kinderwagen sein.
Ja, also da stehen auch irgendwelche Werte, was die für eine Reichweite haben und so. Und da ist halt Batterie, da ist auch ein Gyro, glaube ich, drin.
Ja, da oben gleich mit Griff zum Wegschmeißen. Und wahrscheinlich kannst du diese Standflächen auch einklappen.
Na, der eine steigt auch gleich in den Bus. Guck dir mal, dieses andere, was wir auf der Webseite hatten.
Solo Wheel Instructions, vielleicht das hier.
Oder was? Ja, warte mal, Solo Wheel. Also es gab von Solo Wheel irgendwie...
Und mach mal hier den Bildschirm eine Stufe größer. Da gibt's so einen Button irgendwie.
Wie eine Stufe größer?
Na, du hast jetzt die kleine Größe, es gibt irgendwie, genau.
Nein, keine Ads, YouTube, ey.
So, was möchtest du denn jetzt sehen?
Ja, ich...
Wenn es einpackt oder was? Die sehen aber wirklich sehr ähnlich aus hier im Monobil.
Ja, vielleicht sind das auch die gleichen. Und der eine macht nur Lizenz, irgendwie Reseller.
So, an der Seite da mit seinen Beinen, die muss man dann so heran drücken, damit das Ding nicht zwischen den Beinen kippelt, hat man so weiche Polster oder wie?
Macht den Eindruck, ja. Ein bisschen Führung auch.
Aber guckt euch ansonsten vielleicht nochmal Monowheel-Tricks an. Ich glaube, die sind die...
Jetzt muss man auch erstmal aufsteigen. Achso, aber das macht man, indem man so das Bein...
Mit den Beinen dagegen drückt....
dagegen drückt und dann...
Kannst nicht wegkippen, ja.
Kannst wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch, aber... Aha.
Muss man halt am Anfang ein bisschen üben mit dem Aufsteigen, denke ich.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich wie bei Fahrradfahren.
Genau, sie meinen halt auch so, es braucht irgendwie 30 Minuten, muss man einmal so checken, wie es so geht. Und dann...
Einmal kurz anschubsen und dann drauf treten, so. Okay, also...
Aber das sieht jetzt wirklich nach der Fortbewegung, nach dem Fortbewegungsmittel der Zukunft aus, oder? Weil ich meine, es verbraucht keinen Platz. Du verbrauchst nicht mehr Platz als ein normaler Typ, der da langläuft, nicht wirklich. Du bist zehn Zentimeter höher als sonst. Das heißt, die können gleich mal anfangen, alle Türen zehn Zentimeter höher zu machen, weil ich will mir nicht hier rüber einkloppen. Und das ist das Ding.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen... Also, vor Hoverboard ist das so der nächste Schritt auf jeden Fall.
Also, was ich reizvoll finde, ist das kompakte Maß.
Deswegen sind die Segway-Jungs wahrscheinlich jetzt auch richtig am Arsch.
Ach, weiß nicht, Segway... Also, ich meine, hier kannst du jetzt... Ich meine, so richtig stehen kannst du darauf, aber nicht...
Na, tut er doch.
Nö, das steigt dann gleich wieder ab.
Du meinst, mit anhalten oder was?
Ah, jetzt steht er.
Ja, das hat denn auch ein Gyro wohl drin.
Ach so, das Ding rotiert und...
Also, ich glaube, gelesen zu haben, dass die auch ein Gyro drin haben, aber das kann ja nicht sehr groß sein, ne?
Du meinst, was die ganze Zeit am Drehen ist, um es stabil zu halten? Wie viel Energie willst du dafür raushauen?
Nur, wenn er steht.
Ach so, ja, okay, könnte natürlich sein. Nur, wenn er steht und wenn beide Füße drauf sind, dann rollt er einfach weiter. Du musst halt selber wissen, ob du dann gerade Energie verschwenden willst oder nicht. Könnte sein. Aber eigentlich steigen die schon immer ab, wenn sie anhalten. Eigentlich müssten sie jetzt nur noch eine kleine Stange dran machen oder irgendwie so. Und dann...
Zum Ostziehen, ne?
Nee, dann könnte auch jeder das Ding fahren, ohne dass man sich irgendwie anstrengen muss.
Dann gibt es noch mit Band.
Zum Üben wahrscheinlich am Anfang, damit es leichter losgeht.
Aber mit Band sieht albern aus.
Ja, wenn du Profi bist, lässt es dann weg später.
Aber da gibt es noch so ein Video Solowheel Tricks oder Monowheel Tricks und da machen sie auch wirklich noch abgefahrene Moves, wo man sich denkt, ok, da hast du also richtig Kontrolle über das Ding.
Machen wir auch gleich mal den Link-Sharen.
Ja genau, dann fahren sie hier so irgendwie schön auf so dünnen Mauern. Also es sind jetzt hier nicht sowieso, man soll jetzt nicht erwarten, dass hier irgendwelche X-Games, Skateboarder, Looping Tricks oder so kommen, sondern irgendwie...
Das wird bestimmt nicht lange auf sich warten lassen.
Er ist gerade rückwärts gefahren, er fällt mit einem Bein nur drauf, auf so einer dünnen Rehling. Also irgendwie scheint man auf jeden Fall ganz gut so das unter Kontrolle zu haben.
Gibt es das auch noch in einer Offroad-Variante?
Ein halber breiterer Reifen, fertig.
Guck mal, er fällt schon mal hier einen Berg hoch damit.
Das ist ja auch cool. Oh Gott, aber da wird der Akku nicht lange halten können, denke ich mal.
Deswegen geht es ja auch wieder abwärts. Wie hat er jetzt die Richtung gewechselt, oder hat er es gedreht?
Unklar.
Oder macht der wechselt von alleine die Richtung, wenn man mit den Füßen schräg nach hinten geht?
Wahrscheinlich. Also irgendwie scheint es auch, mit einem Fuß, wenn man da einfach... Also es gibt da scheinbar schon irgendwie Leute mit viel Spaß dabei. Ja, also das hätte ich auch total gerne. Und das für ein Kongress wäre zum Beispiel auch total super, so um da zwischen den Stuhl und so. So voll Jetsons-mäßig, so irgendwie so ein Laptop in der Hand. Genau, mit so einem MacBook Air.
Wobei ein Segway fände ich an der Stelle eigentlich auch ganz cool. Aber ein Segway ist halt groß. Damit kannst du auch noch einen Fahrstuhl rein.
So sieht es aus. Das ist das Ding.
In dem einen Video nimmt er den auch so und steigt in den Bus ein und steigt ab, klappt die Fußraste ein, steigt in den Bus ein, fährt damit und es wiegt irgendwie auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Müssen wir mal gucken hier nochmal.
Locker 15 Kilo, oder?
Nee, nee, das war nicht so viel, glaube ich.
Echt?
Was? Wenn wir nicht vorstellen.
Also irgendwie war das...
Ja doch, da musste auch eine fette Batterie drin sein.
Wir ja nicht nur 10 Minuten fahren, sondern einen halben Tag.
Ja, ist ja schon klar, aber ich habe ja geguckt mal schon.
Und was kostet die Dinger so? Die Säckweiß kostet 4000 Dollar oder so.
Ich glaube, das war so bei 2000.
Ist ja auch ganz schön fett noch.
Wobei, ich finde ja auch diese Elektroroller eigentlich einen guten Kompromiss. Hier in der Raumfahrt Agentur steht einer rum. Jetzt habe ich wieder vergessen, wie das Scheißteil heißt.
Na war auch schon wieder zu groß eigentlich, oder?
Na ja, ein Roller kannst du halt prima zusammenklappen.
Also, die Specs vom Solo-Wheel, nur mal kurz. Es kann 16 kmh fahren. Es hat 16 Kilometer Reichweite. Es braucht 1,5 Stunden zu laden. Es wiegt 11 Kilo. Ach echt? Man kann bis zu 99 Kilo damit transportieren.
Wie?
Bin ich raus?
Wie viel Kilo? 99 Max Load.
Da gibt es zwar bestimmt noch die HD-Version, die wiegt dann 13 und die kann ja auch ein bisschen mehr. Kann nicht so schwer sein.
Motor Power 1000.
Mal aber abgesehen, wenn alle mit so einem Ding rumfahren, dann wiegen demnächst alle über 100 Kilo.
Weil bewegt sich ja keiner mehr. Also die Specks vom Solowheel sind das. Vielleicht hat das Monowheel mehr, aber das Ding ist, ich glaube dein Monowheel war das, was man noch nicht kaufen kann.
Also das Einzige, was diese Industrie noch lösen muss, ist das Problem mit der Batterie. Das gilt für Elektroautos, Elektro-Segways, Elektro-Roller, Elektro-alles. Für Phones und Tablets und Rechner und alles, alles. Jungs, baut ordentliche Batterien.
Oh, es gibt sogar Scooter mit Straßenzulassung. Ich dachte, die hinten alle noch keinen.
Ah ja, Monowheel ist die swedische... Swedish Company. Und Swedish Company ist... Ah, die haben hier auch schon eine neuere Version, die ein bisschen fischer aussieht. Allerdings ist halt alles auf Swedish. Das ist leider ein bisschen blöd. Ach, guck an. Also das Monowheel, das kann weiterfahren. Aber kann es auch mehr transportieren. Ah, die Monowheel-Webseite, die ist irgendwie total kaputt. Die Schweden, die haben es nicht raus mit dem Internet.
Ah ja, das ist jetzt die entsprechende andere Variante, die ich nämlich auch ganz geil finde. Wo man den Flash Player braucht, um das scheiß Video abzuspielen.
Tolle Wurst.
Das ist schon besser.
Das Monowheel kostet angeblich 9999 Swedish Kronas.
Aber was sagen Sie, wie schnell man damit ist?
16 kmh.
So, jetzt guck dir mal das Teil an. Also der E-Grid, da gibt es auch noch andere, aber den habe ich jetzt irgendwie auch gesehen. Der hat aber keine Straßenzulassung. Deswegen muss man wahrscheinlich hier auch in diesem Video gerade so beherzt über den Zebrastreifen und die Bürgersteigbretter. Das Teil hat unten so einen Jumper, und da kannst du das zwischen 17, 25 und 30 kmh konfigurieren.
Aber nicht so richtig schön irgendwie hinzumaulen.
Das ist halt wie ein normaler Roller. Du stellst dich drauf, kickst das Ding einmal an, und dann kannst du vorne den Griff ziehen und Gas geben. Du musst den sozusagen einmal kurz in Bewegung setzen, und dann kannst du halt einfach drauf stehen bleiben und Gas geben. Und das Ding brettert einfach los, wie nichts Gutes. Und wenn du den aber zusammenklappst, dann ist der halt auch echt kompakt. Weil das ist ja nichts. Das ist ja nicht so schön wie bei diesem Solo-Wheel. Aber ehrlich gesagt, vom Coolness-Faktor her, wenn du die ganze Zeit da wirklich so ein Ei zwischen den Beinen hast, und dann auch deine Beine irgendwie nicht lässig...
Da müsstest du schon auch gar nicht mehr auf die Knie gehen.
Also ich hab diesen Asiaten da auf diesem Ding gesehen, und der sah so maximal entspannt aus. Denen hat es überhaupt nicht interessiert, was um ihn rum geht. Und wie der da um diese Retner dann plötzlich so rumgefahren ist. Das war wirklich eine cooles Demonstration, möchte ich sagen.
Na gut, also da tut sich was. Ich finde, diese ganze Elektromobilität, das wird noch echt spaßig. Aber mit so einem Teil kannst du halt auch wirklich nennenswerte Strecken schnell abwickeln.
Aber da ist doch ein Fahrrad eigentlich wieder zu groß, sagst du.
Ein Fahrrad hat halt vor allem das Problem, wenn du halt schnell die Strecke überbrücken willst, dann kommst du halt verschwitzt an.
Wieso, da hast du doch den Elektromotor.
Achso, ja gut, aber das ist halt viel zu fett und schwer dann.
Wie viel wiegt der in so einem Roller?
15 Kilo.
Also vom Gewicht her kriegst du das auch als Fahrrad.
Ja locker, kriegst du zwei dafür. Zwei Rennräder.
Aber kein E-Fahrrad.
Aber ein E-Fahrrad dürfte jetzt auch nicht so viel schwerer sein als das da.
Also ein Monobil war bei 11 Kilo.
Na gut, aber ein Fahrradschmeißer hast du halt nicht immer im Kofferraum.
Welches Auto bräuchte alles nicht da?
Doch, gerade, weil ich meine, wo kannst du heute schon noch zentral parken?
Ich vor der Tür.
Naja, wenn du irgendwie auf dem Dorf wohnst vielleicht.
Nee, mit meinem Moped.
Naja eben. Alles so eine Sache.
Alles so eine Sache.
Aber wenn du ein Auto hast und sowieso schon wieder bist du noch nah am Ziel, dann musst du auch eigentlich dieses Solo-Wheel reichen. Dann willst du noch so ein paar Meter fahren, oder?
Nein, wir werden ja sehen, was wir so alles so am Start haben an Mobilität.
Wir werden alle im Rollstuhl sitzen später.
Mit dem Jumper auf 32 kmh, verstehst du? Spiel mal Mario Kart in der Marienstraße.
Ja, ich meine so ein Elektrorollstuhl wäre auch ganz nett.
Da kann man da wirklich bequem sitzen und durchhacken.
Und wenn du dann auch noch irgendwie so ein bisschen automatische Navigation hast, wenn man dann mal so ein Leitsystem vielleicht auch nochmal bringt. Also du machst dann quasi so eine E-Rolli-Seidenstraße, wo du dann quasi so Bodenmarkierungen hast. Und dann geht das so ein bisschen ab wie hier so Daimler-Benz mit ihren autonomen Autos auf der Autobahn.
Ganz ein Hacker im Rollstuhl, der die ganze Zeit durch die gegengefahrene, dynamischen Gruppierungen zugeführt.
So sieht's aus.
Also sind wir vom Kongress zu diesem Ding hier gekommen?
Es ist wirklich blöd, dass diese Webseite komplett neu entsteht.
Hat bei dem Kongress schon alles durch, ja?
Eigentlich schon.
Ich denke ja. Also die Seidenstraße, die...
Die sollen wir noch erwähnen.
Na, die wollen da... Es gibt schon von woanders so ein Projekt, das wird jetzt auch auf dem Kongress verwirklicht. Und zwar, dass man durch... Es gibt ja diese... Habt ihr schon mal, wenn die Autobahnen neu bauen, dann gehen ja immer so eine gelben Schläuche am Rand weg, damit die das Wasser wegfüllen, wenn die Straße noch neu ist und kein Rand hat oder irgendwie so. Drainageschläuche. Genau, wahrscheinlich damit die Böschung, die sie da bauen, damit die nicht vom Regen unterspült wird, falls es mal doll regnet. Weil, welchen Grund solltest du sonst haben, dass die es da einsammeln und dann doch da runterjagen? Muss ja irgendwie sowas sein, ne?
Ja.
Jedenfalls, diese gelben Schläuche, die so geriffelt sind, davon wurde ganz viel besorgt. Ich weiß nicht, was haben die für einen Durchmesser, so 20 Zentimeter circa, ja, ne? Und dann nehmen sie einen Staubsauger, machen auf einer, also stecken eine Flasche rein mit irgendeiner Sache drin und machen einen Staubsauger dran, den sie auf Pumpen setzen und drücken diese Flasche dann durch diesen Schlauch durch, damit er dann auf der anderen Seite von dem Schlauchsystem wieder ankommt. Und das machen die mit mehreren Schläuchen an verschiedenen Orten.
Mach mal dein Abdeck nicht auf, ich hab dir da so einen Link geschickt.
Und das Gleiche geht auch rückwärts mit Saugen. Und da war ich auch schon in einer Raumfahrtagentur, die bereitet sowas vor. Und dann haben wir schon, ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Stock ich gewesen bin, ich bin ganz nach oben geladet mit einem Schlauch. Wir haben zwei 10-Meter-Stücke einander gemacht. Und haben das auf jeden Fall die dritte oder vierte Etage dann hochgepumpt. Und das war kein Problem, weil im Gegensatz zu irgendwelchen Systemen, die Wasser irgendwo hochdrücken, das Wasser wird dann immer schwerer oder es wird immer mehr Wasser, was in der Leite steht. Das ist ja bei Luft nicht der Fall. Das heißt, das macht keinen Unterschied. Und deswegen kam die Flasche prima oben an.
Also diesen Link, den Tim jetzt gerade brauchst, den kann er auch gleich nochmal in den Chat packen. Weil das ist quasi die Projektseite zu diesem Projekt. Und da geht es darum, wie das Addressing Scheme sein wird für diese Rohrpost, wie der Netzwerkplan ist, welche Staubsauger kompatibel sind, wo man dieses Drainagerohr kaufen kann. Da ist auch ein Link, Tim, falls du eine Note werden willst oder irgendwie Teile der Strecke stellen willst. Da gibt es auch einen Link, wo man dieses Drainagerohr bestellen kann. Kostet auch nicht so viel. Es gibt irgendwie Staubsaugerlisten, die kompatibel sind. Und da kann man sich schon mal vorbereiten. Da steht auch drin, ja genau hier, Pressure Sources 3.2. Da sind zum Beispiel die paar Staubsauger irgendwie verlinkt, die da schon früher brauchbar erklärt wurden. Kärcher. Ja, aber auch so dieser Shop-Wack, der kann lohnen und ist ganz billig. Der kostet nur 60 Euro. Und dann gibt es noch diesen Zentral-Staubsauger, den finde ich ja besonders charmant.
Ja, wo es einen Ein- und Ausgang gibt, wo man dann umswitchen kann.
WD-3002.
Ansonsten, wenn die Hacker-Spaces das irgendwie machen, dann können sie ja gleich gucken, ob sie einen Staubsauger finden, den sie danach auch gleich behalten wollen, weil Staubsauger kann ja nie schaden.
Der Kärcher kostet auch nur 60. Nass-Trockensauer, 60 Euro, echt?
Wir müssen gucken, was die Filter kosten. So läuft das. Sieh mit den Druckern. Wahrscheinlich hab ich sogar recht, oder?
Das ist ein Saugbläser. Filterkosten. Naja, wohl, der Filterpatrone kostet 13 Euro. Geht ja noch.
Eine.
Ich frage jetzt, wie oft ihr die wechseln müsst, nicht was sie kostet.
Naja, für die Seidenstraße, um Zeug durch die Rohre zu schicken, musst du sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht wechseln oder nicht mal drin haben.
Das mindert nur die Saugleistung.
So sieht es aus.
Shopwack.
Da steht auch der Preis.
Super 1300. Inox.
Wir erzählen gleich nach Erfehlet links fischen.
Ich gucke einfach, ob der hier eigentlich im deutschen Markt so ohne weiteres verfügbar ist, weil das ist ja hier unsere komische EU. Ja, okay, hier kann man wohl auch bestellen. Keine Ahnung, aber da kommen wir hin.
Aber der Kerscher kostet ja genauso viel.
Jaja, passt schon.
Der sieht auch schicker aus. Wobei, vielleicht hat der mehr Bums hier.
Tja, weiß nicht. Sieht aber nicht so geil aus.
Schick noch mal den Zentralstaubsauger an.
Jungs, habt ihr das gehört? Die suchen jetzt schon Staubsauger aus, je nachdem wie die aussehen.
Da oben in der Liste war noch hier, wartet der? Nein, nein, nein, bei den Saugern, bei den Pressure Sources. Pressure Sources. War da nicht noch ein Link zu dem Zentralsauger? Den haben sie so rausgenommen.
Zentralsauger?
Also wie gesagt, da machst du dir dann Löcher in die Wand und dann hast du einen großen Sauger in irgendeinem Kämmerlein und kannst dann deinen Rohr überall neistipseln.
Ja, und einfach Petflaschen rein.
Also ganz toll wäre natürlich, wenn man transparente Drainageschläuche hätte, ein Freund von mir hat erzählt, dass er mal bei einer Party war, wo sie auch dieses ganze Party-Areal mit transparenten Rohren oder Schläuchen ausgebaut haben und dann auch so Leuchtzeug da rein in die Flasche. Und dann nachts hat man diese Rohre halt nicht mehr gesehen, sondern nur noch die Dinge und haben dann irgendwelche Schleifen und so gebaut und ist dann da irgendwie durch die Party geflohen. Das klingt natürlich auch sehr gut.
Hier gibt es einen Netzplan.
Das sind die Nerd-Zeiten. Und sie wollen halt auch Onion-Routing implementieren.
Innen, Außen, Durchbruch, Handvermittlung. So ist da das Routing.
Da kommt das Fräulein vom Amt.
Können Sie mich mal nach sowieso durchstellen?
Das Herrlein vom Amt.
Das Herrlein vom Amt darf dann mal was ins Rohr eintüten.
Ja, und es wäre natürlich jetzt total großartig, wenn es dann wirklich so Silkroad-mäßig tor. Also so, hier schmeißt du mal eine ausgedruckte Bitcoin rein. Da kriegst du den Beutel Gras zurück. Weiß nicht, wo es herkommt, weiß nicht, wo es hingeht.
Das war jetzt aber nur rein hypothetisch.
Natürlich.
Wie heißt das Projekt.
Nochmal? Seidenstraße. Es ist nicht armer in Humor, aber ich find's geil. Ich hab mich in den letzten Wochen und Monaten enorm viel mit Leuten über den 30C3 unterhalten, die da noch nie waren. Aber die großes Interesse daran hatten, da hinzukommen.
Warte, ich muss noch eine Sache kurz in den Chat posten. Es gibt ja ein Testlaufvideo von der Raumfahrtagentur, wo sie mit LEDs nämlich schon eine Runde mal gedreht haben. Das könnt ihr euch jetzt mit diesem Vimeo-Link anschauen. Und Tim erzählt jetzt weiter, wie viele Leute er schon gesprochen hat.
Das ist, wo Frank der kurz einmal eine Runde macht.
Ich hab noch nie was vom Kongress gehört haben. Ja, das kenn ich schon.
Es gibt auch immer noch ganz viele Leute, die nicht wissen, was ein Cookie ist und so.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie macht man jemanden klar, dass der Kongress anders ist als andere Veranstaltungen? Wenn dich einer fragt, wie ist denn das mit diesem Kongress? Dann kannst du dir sagen, ja, das ist total toll, das sind total tolle Menschen und die führen total tolle Gespräche und es ist überhaupt alles total toll. Du musst unbedingt kommen. Ich meine, erzählen die auch Teenager über ACDC-Konzerte? Also gut, heutzutage wahrscheinlich weniger die Teenager als die hängen gebliebenen Mit-Fünfziger, aber wissen schon, was ich meine. Oder Justin Bieber oder you name it, was auch jetzt gerade angesagt ist.
Ja, fragst du uns.
Justin Bieber ist auch schon wieder out, wie auch immer. Ja, ein bisschen, was ich meine. Ich reduziere es dann immer ganz gerne auf diese Infrastrukturleistung, die auf diesem Kongress erbracht wird. Die für uns vollkommen selbstverständlich ist. Aber sag mir mal irgendeine andere Veranstaltung, für die das irgendwie der Standard ist. Dass man dann am besten, wenn man eine neue Location hat, erst mal so unterirdisch so lange gräbt, bis man auf Glasfasern stößt. Über die man sich dann möglichst gleich mit drei, vier oder fünf Internet-Providern gleichzeitig verbindet und überhaupt erst mal die Basisversorgung, Netz.
Ja, ohne Netz geht ja nix, ne?
Um dann eine Infrastruktur im Haus zu legen, wo man nicht nur Gigabit Ports bekommt, sondern vermutlich auch, wenn der Server auf der Gegenseite im Netz in der Lage ist, das auch rauszutun, dieses Gigabit wirklich komplett auch durch das Internet transportiert bekommt. Weil da einfach genug Luft ist. Na ja, gut, aber verstehst du, das kennt ja keiner.
Doch, Leute aus der Uni.
Und dann hab ich so gestaunt. Ja gut, aber ich meine, eine Uni ist halt auch über Jahre mit x Millionen Förderkohle. Und dann, nach zehn Jahren, lief es dann halt auch mal. Aber diese Veranstaltung wird innerhalb von drei Tagen aus dem Boden gestampft. Über Weihnachten.
24.
Weihnachten fahren Leute raus irgendwie und bauen dann diese Infrastruktur. Die dann auch funktioniert. Und dann auch so ein WLAN oben drauf. Das hat mein Hirn gesprengt letztes Jahr. Dass ich wirklich so in diesem Saal einsaß, 3000 Leute um mich herum, also gefühlt 6700 WLAN-Devices.
Und du hattest WLAN?
Von denen wahrscheinlich ein Drittel an Betrieb waren, also umgeben von 3000 aktiven WLAN-Devices. Und ich hatte nicht nur Netz, nein, ich konnte mir in HD-Qualität das Video des Nachbarsals auf meinen Bildschirm streamen und nichts ruckelte.
Tja, kannst du mal sehen, so weit ist schon gekommen.
Genau, das einfach mal amtlich. Und dann, wie selbstverständlich, gibt es natürlich dann auch noch ein Telefonnetzwerk für schnurlose Telefone. Was noch so als Nottelefon in der Tasche ist.
Jeder, der zum Kongress kommt, kann sein Decktelefon mitbringen, sich da anmelden, kriegt eine Nummer und ist dann vor Ort erreichbar. Und ich glaube, es gibt sogar kostenlose Telefonie weltweit. Irgendwie so. Und kann rein erreicht werden. Und auch raus. Oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau.
Und du kannst halt mal auch eben für den Vortrag, den du dir anschaust und du sprichst vielleicht kein Deutsch, und der ist aber auf Deutsch, dann kannst du halt eine bestimmte Nummer wählen und dann hast du die Übersetzung auf dem Ohr.
Und dieses Decknetz gibt es auch noch als GSM-Netz, weil wir haben auch unser eigenes GSM-Netz vor Ort.
Da war ich ja noch gar nicht.
Ich wollte jetzt noch ein neues Decknetz.
Dann kommt noch was, verstehe ich.
Na klar, da gibt es noch 1000 Dienstleistungen. Angenommen, du kommst nicht rechtzeitig hin. Oder angenommen, du musst aufs Klo während einer Veranstaltung. Das ist eigentlich total spannend. Was willst du machen?
Ruf einfach die Nummer an und hörst live weiter.
Hörst einfach auf dem Klo so lange weiter, bis du wieder auf deinem Platz bist und dann übernimmst du wieder die PL. Das ist einfach ein Konferenz-Lifestyle, der dann gelebt werden kann, like no other.
Hat dir nicht auch mal so eine Sex-Nummer oder sowas? So ein Spaß? Irgendwo war da.
Gab's eine Porno-Hotline?
Irgendwo, genau.
Es gibt da überhaupt alle möglichen Sachen. Sascha baut da immer wieder so haarsträubende Lösungen. Ist auch mit allem gekoppelt.
Die Radio, wir haben ja auch Radio vor Ort. Das Radio ist auch per Deck erreichbar. Das ist auch eine Nummer. Dann haben wir natürlich eine Notruf-Nummer. Das zährt. Also man kann lokal den Notruf rufen. Ist das nicht einfach zu 1 1 2 oder 1 1 0?
Es gibt überhaupt Nummern für alle Fälle.
Und da ist kein Spaß dahinter, sondern hinter der 1 1 2. Also wenn es die 1 1 2 ist, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, da ist wirklich ein Zert hinter mit Leuten, die das sonst irgendwie auch machen und die kommen dann.
Genau, weil der Hauscomputer Club auch der einzige Computer Club der Welt ist, der auch noch seine eigene Medical Unit hat. Mit kranken Waren. Genau, das ist das, was ich meine. Also diese total abgefahrenen Infrastrukturen, die sich da jetzt über die Jahre aufgebaut haben. Und last but not least, du hast es schon erwähnt, ein eigenes GSM-Netzwerk. Das heißt, man kann dann vor Ort auch noch eine SIM-Karte erwerben, die in sein Telefon, gegebenenfalls ins Zweit-Telefon, reinbauen. Und dann ist man sozusagen lokal auch weitgehend abhörsicher unterwegs. Und das kann man auch noch mit einem normalen GSM-Telefon machen, was dann vermutlich auch wiederum mit der DECT-Telefonanlage verbunden ist, sodass man dann auch wieder angerufen werden kann.
Achso, das Labyrinth gibts noch per Telefon, höre ich gerade.
Das Labyrinth? Audio-Abenteuer oder was?
Ja, ich weiß nicht so genau, habe es nie benutzt.
Du stehst vor einer Wand?
Geradeaus drücken sie 2, 4 oder 6.
Es ist einfach unglaublich, was sich da in den letzten 10 Jahren entwickelt hat.
Bei GSM müsstet ihr am besten zusätzlich noch ein zweites Telefon mitnehmen, damit euer anderes weiter erreichbar ist. Weil ihr könnt dann vor Ort für 2,50 Euro oder so euch eine GSM-Karte kaufen, die dann in diesem Netz funktioniert. Und dann habt ihr noch ein Telefon, mit dem ihr über GSM erreichbar seid. Eigentlich auch ganz schick. Also wenn auch so ein altes 6310i in der Ecke liegen hat, nicht wegschmeißen, mitbringen, Karte rein, fertig. Ja, ich hab nur eins.
Meine Schwester hat's in die Ostsee fallen lassen.
Gibt's doch bestimmt auf Ebay.
Aber so eng langsam, es gibt nicht mehr so viele.
Es gibt angeblich immer noch original verpackt und Air Ride und so.
Da gibt's noch ganz andere Sachen original verpackt.
Genau, wenn ihr ein Deck-Telefon habt, dann schaut nochmal, ob das auch kompatibel ist. Da gibt's in dem Kongress-Wiki gibt's auch so eine Liste von kompatiblen Geräten, weil nicht alle Deck-Telefone auf dem Markt sind tatsächlich auch mit dieser Telefonanlage kompatibel. Also wenn die halt den normalen Standard implementieren, dann ist das okay, aber es gibt da so Schrott von...
Rutsch mit Flower Power.
Ja, nee, auch teilweise irgendwelche...
was war denn das? Was hatte ich denn da?
Siemens, ich glaube Siemens geht immer, das andere geht irgendwie nicht.
Keine Ahnung, schaut nach.
Du meinst Siemens, meinst du mit Gigaset, wo es auch gar nicht mehr Siemens gehört?
Ja, ich weiß jetzt bloß nicht mehr, ob die Gigaset ging oder die Gigaset nicht ging, aber ich glaube die Gigaset waren die, die immer gingen.
Die Gigaset gingen, weil ich hab so eins und das geht.
Genau, ich hatte so einen Phillips-Teil und das ging nicht.
Ja, also jemandem zu erklären, wie cool der Kongress ist, ist schon weiterhin schwierig, weil man kann sich das einfach nicht vorstellen.
Nee, aber man merkt das sofort, wenn man da ist.
Wer zweifelt und vielleicht jetzt nicht allzu weit weg ist, der soll einfach mal vorbeikommen, sich an den Eingang stellen und wenn er dann nicht das gecheckt hat, dann ist vielleicht auch Hopfen und Malz verloren.
Aber es ist halt auch ein ganz anderer Schlag, Menschen. Das finde ich auch sowieso. Da sind ja nicht nur CCC-Nerds, sondern auch Dunstkreis und Satelliten und andere Paralleluniversen. Aber trotzdem ist das irgendwie, weiß nicht, so. Immer wenn die Leute mich fragen, hier guckste, wie heißen die Big Bang-Series oder wie auch immer, wo er die Nerds oder eher so total überzogen und so weiter dargestellt hat. Das sind ja nicht die Nerds.
Das sind auch die Nerds.
Das sind auch Nerds.
Schauspieler, die Nerds spielen.
Aber das ist halt nicht so, wie ich jetzt so Nerds und Hacker halt so, also Hacker, das ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Kategorie, aber da, weiß nicht, da, das ist einfach so ein ganz anderer Vibe. Das ist so immer noch, wenn ich irgendwie daran denke, wie ich das erste Mal in den Club gekommen bin, da war mir auch irgendwie sofort klar, das ist jetzt hier ein ganz anderes Universum und die Leute hier, die haben so ein ganz anderes Bild von, wie die Welt funktioniert und für alles auch ihre eigene Erklärung und sowieso dieser Hackergeist so geht nicht, gibt's nicht und man findet schon eine Lösung für jedwede Probleme und man kriegt auch auf einem Bauernhof mitten in der Pampa irgendwie Internet für ein paar hundert Leute hin, wenn man mal an den richtigen Nummern anruft und mal so einen grauen Kasten aufschraubt und sie ein bisschen auskennt. Also weißt du, so dieser ganze Drive, diese ganze, naja, weiß nicht, irgendwie Mentalität ist auch so komplett anders, wenn ich noch nirgendswo anders so in der Form...
Ja und vor allem, wer sich darüber Gedanken macht. Was man ja auch schnell denken können würde, ist so, oh Gott, das sind jetzt so die totalen Super-Freaks und ich hab ja keine Ahnung und mit mir redet ja keiner und so. Also das mag es auch geben, aber das ist definitiv nicht der vorherrschende Flair. Also ich hab das schon weitgehend als extrem inklusiv erlebt. Und zwar jetzt nicht, was ich jetzt persönlich da erlebe, weil dafür stehe ich dem viel zu nahe, aber was man so aus Blog-Artikeln rausliest, was man von anderen Leuten später so erzählt bekommt, Sternstunde fand ich gerade jetzt beim letzten Mal im 29C3 diesen Blog-Eintrag von einer Mädel, die irgendwie chronische Autistin ist und die überhaupt schon mal große Menschenansammlungen überhaupt nicht verkraften kann. Und dann irgendwie von ihrem Freund sogar noch mit so einem Warn-T-Shirt ausgestattet wurde, wie man denn mit ihr am besten nicht umzugehen hat, wegen einfach den Autisten, also manchen Formen des Autismus, ist das ja so, dass das dann einfach alles zu viel ist, die irgendwie fluchtartig den Raum verlassen müssten. Aber das fand da halt alles nicht statt. Total rührende Story. Ich hab den Link jetzt überhaupt nicht zur Hand, aber der dürfte sich finden lassen, vielleicht von Show-Notes-Menschen.
Das wär ganz toll.
Und ähnliche Geschichten, das ist jetzt vielleicht schon ein extremes Beispiel. Grundsätzlich hab ich immer wieder erlebt, man kommt dahin als Fremder. Und die Leute sagen danach so, es ist ja irgendwie egal. Hier geht es irgendwie gar nicht um Computer oder so. Hier geht es um so eine gewisse Haltung dem Leben und der Gesellschaft gegenüber. Geht nicht, geht nicht, gibt es nicht. Man muss irgendwie alles hinterfragen. Man muss aber dabei auch möglichst viel Spaß haben. Und dieser ganze Wahnsinn, der drückt sich dann einfach an jedem einzelnen Tisch aus. Allein diese ganzen kleinen Installationen, die da immer wieder entstehen, irgendwie aberwitzige Hacks aus irgendwas. Die Seitenstraße ist immer wieder das beste Beispiel. Wir bauen jetzt mal aus Fettflaschen und Drainagerohren eine Rohrpost. Das ist genau das Ding. Also Baustoffe zu Kommunikationsinfrastrukturen. Tja. Haben wir eigentlich alles gesagt, wa?
Hingehen.
Hingehen. Und wer nicht kommt, selber Schuld? Ach ja, der Termin?
Hab ich schon gesagt am Anfang.
Ja, ist schwierig, aber geht schon irgendwie. Weil eigentlich ist eh langweilig die Zeit.
Außer, wenn man seine Familie ganz weit weg besuchen muss. Das gibt's ja nicht. Was mir gerade noch so einfällt, wo wir so viel von Infrastruktur reden und von WLAN und auf Konferenzen und so weiter, es ist ja leider Gottes im 21. Jahrhundert, im Jahre 2013 immer noch der Fall, dass man auf Konferenzen fährt und das WLAN sackt. Und zwar richtig, richtig doll. So, also es sackt nicht mehr, es geht einfach nicht. Zum Beispiel war ich in einer Konferenz, die wirklich sehr toll war in Barcelona, Baruko und das WLAN. Sie hatten zwei Access Points für die obere Etage und zwei Access Points für die untere.
Für wie viele Teilnehmer?
So 500, 600. Und sie haben alle Fehler gemacht, die man halt so machen kann. So irgendwie 4, 2,4 Gigahertz und 5 Gigahertz auf einem Access Point und den ganzen Shit. Und der Tilo von Co-op hier, der hat, ich glaube auch mit Clemens oder zumindest mit New Thinking, mit Wetterfrosch und so weiter, hat ja so einen Blogpost ja mal kompiliert. The Conference Wi-Fi Checklist. Und wenn irgendjemand von euch eine Konferenz mit organisiert oder auch nur irgendwie da irgendwie die Finger im Spiel hat und es geht um das Thema WLAN, dann empfehle ich euch zumindest diesen Post da zu beherzigen. Ich denke, das meiste davon, da würde auch der Clemens keine Einwände haben. Und auf jeden Fall ist das schon mal alles, geht das in die richtige Richtung im Vergleich zu, ach da schmeiß mal zwei Axis-Points in die Ecke und das wird schon irgendwie reichen. Also ich fand das eine ganz gute Zusammenfassung mal von den ganzen Lessons learned aus den vergangenen Jahren und so weiter und so fort. Und sollte Clemens noch Verbesserungen haben, dann soll er die mal da mit einpflegen. Aber prinzipiell finde ich das ganz gut, so eine Checklist mal unter das Volk zu mischen und allen in die Hand zu drücken, die auch nur ansatzweise mal so 100 Leute oder 200 Leute mit WLAN auch bespaßen wollen.
Aber warum, meinst du, ist 2,4 Gigahertz und 5 Gigahertz auf einem Axis-Point ein Problem?
Ja, kommt halt auf die Axis-Points auch an. Ja, nee, an sich geht das natürlich.
Aber ich habe jetzt nicht ganz verstanden, worauf du hinaus wolltest.
Aber wir hatten ja auch mal, dass unsere WLAN-Jungs, die das WLAN-Netz auch gemacht haben auf dem Kongress, dann irgendwie sind alle iPhones immer abgestürzt oder irgendwie sowas. Nee, iPhones nicht, aber die Rechner sind abgestürzt. 10.6 hatte irgendwie der WLAN-Treiber einen Bug oder so und dann haben die den ja auch genau rausgefunden, was das Problem ist und einen Apple-Report gemacht und eine Weile später wurde er dann auch gefixt. Da war doch mal was, zwei, drei Jahre her.
Auf dem Kongress, ja.
Die sind alle abgekackt.
Richtig krass.
Und die wussten dann genau irgendwann, haben es bis aufs Paket runter mal debugged, wie das Paket aussieht, was das Problem ist. Und die hatten auch so eine Einstellung. Da wussten sie, welche Einstellungen man nicht machen sollte, falls Apple das Update noch nicht raus hat, was man nicht einschalten soll. Und Apple wusste dann auch, was sie machen müssen, damit der Körnelpanic nicht mehr kommt. Und dann war das Problem behoben.
Ich glaube, das ist auch teilweise, ich will das jetzt nicht so, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich hab das so am Rande mitbekommen. Ich weiß nicht, was es als Core-Router war, was das letzte Mal verwendet wurde, war das wieder Juniper? Also Cisco, Juniper, die Kategorie, Firmen.
Aus der Liga auf jeden Fall.
Aus der Liga wird ja üblicherweise das Gerät immer so geholt und da ja die Anforderungen des Kongresses auch immer steigen und dann natürlich die Top-Nerds da im Nock auch immer so the latest shit haben wollen, weil es soll ja auch Spaß machen.
Brauchen halt vor allem.
Und aber auch brauchen, genau. Also es muss sozusagen auch immer das Neueste sein.
Weil ein Kongressbesucher macht wahrscheinlich Last wie 20 auf eine anderen Veranstaltung.
Genau, und das ist nämlich exakt der Punkt. Also das Netzwerk auf dem Kongress ist quasi der härteste Test, den man dem brandaktuellen Gerät unterziehen kann. Weil die üblicherweise, wenn die das in ihre Interpreis-Installationen reinbringen oder irgendwelche Fabriken oder Bürokomplexe reinschrauben, wo das dann langsam genutzt wird, bis die da hinkommen, bis die zu diesem Nutzungsgrad kommen. Also wie viele Geräte gleich... Ja, und auch die Vielfalt. Ja, im BCC, jeder hat irgendwie mindestens zwei Devices dabei. Ich glaube, der Schnitt war mal irgendwie so was wie 2,3 MAC-Adressen pro Teilnehmer. Irgendwie so, ja. Das heißt, du hast dann irgendwie bei 3.000 Besuchern so irgendwie was mit 6.000, 7.000 MAC-Adressen. Und dann hat er irgendwie dieser Core-Router, der irgendwie, so wie das da aufgebaut war, auch alle sehen musste. Also alle Ethernet-Stecker, alle WLAN, also alles jetzt. Ja, der hatte dann halt irgendwie eine Tabelle, da passten halt 6.000 rein und dann war sie halt voll. So, was dann dazu führte, dass halt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche rausfielen und so weiter. Und das Ganze halt sich komplett die Karten legte. Und das Problem wurde einerseits.
Ja, aber wer hat dann auch 5.000 Leute und einer Broadcast-Domain?
Ja, das wurde ja dann auch anders gelöst, so nachdem man das festgestellt hat. Und man würde ja nicht davon ausgehen, dass jetzt so ein Gerät, was irgendwie erstmal scheiße viel Geld kostet, so ein dicker fetter Schrank ist und tonnenweise Gigabyte von RAM hat.
Und dann so ein Billig-Limit hat.
Ja, so ein Billig-Limit hat, weil nur irgendein Programmierer da mal gesessen hat, ja, auf was machen wir denn immer diese Tabelle? Ja, irgendwie ist gleich 6.000 so einfach hingeschrieben, ohne Not, ja, und dann war sie halt so groß. Bang und fertig. Aber solche Sachen, teilweise sind es ja auch kritische Fehler, die man jetzt durch einen Workaround nicht so ohne weiteres machen kann, weil die einfach mit der Last nicht klarkommen. Und naja, von den Firmen, die halt dieses Gerät stellen, das ist ja gesponserte Sachen, sind da nicht selten halt auch so ein paar Leute vom Urlaub befreit. Also dürfen keinen nehmen, weil sie halt stand-by sein müssen, weil der Kongress halt gerade läuft. Und da sind also teilweise gehen dann die Emergency Warnings halt noch in den ersten Stunden des Kongresses da raus und dann setzen sich da diese Teams ran und versuchen irgendwie das zu fixen, damit also noch binnen kürzester Zeit die Feuerwehr kommt und neue Firmware eingespielt werden kann, damit dieser Kram läuft. Weil die wissen natürlich auch, so billig kriegen die so ein Auditing von ihrem Kram nie wieder. Ja, ich meine, da läuft irgendwie dieser Kongress- und Härtetest. Stell dir mal vor, du würdest das orchestrieren. Testet doch mal unsere Hardware so richtig bis ins Mark. Da müssten die dann allein für die Consultants die Termine planen, irgendwie schon wahrscheinlich das zehnfache ausgeben von dem, was der Kongress insgesamt kostet. Keine Ahnung.
Und künstlicher Traffic ist halt nicht so schick, wie echter Traffic, der da durchballert. Genau.
Und das ist auch wirklich, ja ich meinte so irgendwie, alles an Traffic, also alles. Alles, was das Internet kann, alles, was das Internet spricht, wird da wahrscheinlich auch gebraucht.
Vor allem alles, was das Internet nicht spricht, wird da auch gebraucht. Was ich gestern noch gehört hab, glaub ich, ich weiß nicht, ob's stimmt, aber kann ich mir gut vorstellen, ist, diese Pakete da, die ganzen Switches und Router und Zeugs kommen ja da palettenweise in großen Kartons an und wenn da das NOC, das ist unser Netzwerkteam, wenn sie den Scheiß zurückschicken, dann schreiben sie wohl mit Eddinger auf die Kartons drauf, was das Problem war. Und sagen hier das und das ging nicht, abgestürzt, was auch immer, keine Ahnung, aber ich hab's gestern gehört, weiß nicht, ob's stimmt, aber kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Naja, also Firmen, die da was sponsern, die haben auch was davon. Also wenn sie wach sind und das Feedback auch wirklich umsetzen, dann ist es das Geld allemal wert gewesen, dieses Gerät bereitzustellen, zumal das Zeug ja meistens sowieso irgendwie verfügbar ist, in irgendeinem Pool steckt und dann über Weihnachten ohnehin von niemanden sonst benutzt wird.
Na, hier das mit dem 2,54 GHz, das soll man halt natürlich, ich glaube der Fehler war früher, dass sie halt diesen Kompatibilitätsmodus da hatten, weißt schon, dieses A-...
Sollte es nicht auf ein Netz gehen, sondern sollen zwei verschiedene Netze machen und so.
Genau, dass es halt schön separiert haben.
Da haben wir ja letztens auch irgendwie diese... Die diesen Standard da machen für die ganzen 802-Punkte. Tralala, dass sie mal gesagt haben, dass B jetzt mal raus muss und so, weil es stört, ne? Na ja, Zeit wird's.
Ja, Zeit wird's. Also es ist im Rahmen von diesem AC, ne? Oder ist es die nächste Stufe?
Der nächste halt AC ist ja jetzt fertig geworden.
Wie heißt die nächste Stufe? Gab's schon einen Namen? WLAN-AD.
WLAN-AD.
WLAN-AD. Ja, B ist böse. B steht für böse. Und das muss weg. Ich mein, das braucht hoffentlich keiner mehr.
Ich glaub, das brauchen auch verdammt viele Leute.
Ja, wer läuft denn mit B-only-Equipment durch die Gegend?
Jedes scheiß embellet Mikro, tralala, sonst, die sind wahrscheinlich alle mit B am Start.
Nee, heutzutage doch nicht.
Ja, bestimmt. Wie das halt immer so ist. Was meinst du, wie viele tausend Leute noch mit Standard-GPS, mit GSM, mit GPS am Start sind? Ohne Ende. Und das auch noch nutzen für irgendeinen Alarmanlagen. Was weiß ich nicht. Weißt du, das ganze Kleinscheiß, an dem man eigentlich nicht denkt, den wir vielleicht auch nicht haben, aber da gibt's glaub ich noch ganz viele Sachen, die halt über B laufen.
B, WLAN ist... Wie alt ist denn das? Das haben wir 1999, das erste Mal WLAN deployed auf dem Kampffol.
Mit diesen komischen Silver- und Gold-Cards oder so. Mit 56 Bit oder 128.
Mehr Verschlüsselung.
Ja, genau.
Richtig.
Orinoco hieß die Scheiße.
Genau. Von drei kommen. Das sind jetzt 14 Jahre. Also es gibt jetzt 14 Jahre lang WLAN in the wild.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann der nächste rauskommt. War das nächste schon G? Hat schon eine Weile gedauert. Das erste war schon ganz lange da.
Gute Frage. 2003 verabschiedet. Also so vier Jahre später.
Sag mal, ist jetzt eigentlich noch Sendung? Oder sollten wir jetzt schon langsam die Schleife einspielen? Weil das faded hier gerade so ein bisschen vor den Händen.
Ende ist 2009 und jetzt kommt P.
Klemenz sagt auch, dass der Embedded-Kram alles schon ein G hat. Kann schon sein, müsste man mal gucken. Also vielleicht können wir ja auch das WLAN-Team auf dem Dock mal anhalten, dass die zum Beispiel mal sagen, wie viele Leute dann noch mit B-Devices da auf dem Kongress rum eiern.
Das Noctime macht bestimmt dieses Jahr einfach gar keinen...
Die machen kein B.
Ja oder so. Und dann wie viele Beschwerden kommen, dass kein B da ist.
Ja, das fände ich mal konsequent, dass man B einfach ausschaltet. Einfach, hier gibt es kein B. Geh weg.
Genau.
Eigentlich kann man wahrscheinlich sogar schon auf G verzichten.
Haben ganz viele Telefone, haben nur G. Dein Telefon hat zum Beispiel...
Wie?
Dein Vierer hat noch kein G, oder?
Ach so, das Vierer?
Und wenn es G hat, dann nicht ein Fünf-Fieger-Herz.
Nein, es hat kein N.
Ah, ja stimmt.
G haben die alle.
Jaja, hast recht, hast echt. Der N gibt es ja auch noch. Mann, ist das schon wieder Zeug am Start.
Ne, G haben sie alle, aber auf G kann man jetzt nicht verzichten, weil N haben nicht alle.
Ja, N ist ja auch noch gerade mal abgelöst.
Also N auf 5 Gigahertz haben nicht alle. Also das iPhone 5 war ja das erste, was überhaupt 5 Gigahertz konnte. Naja, wir wiederholen uns und ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier auch irgendwie genug geredet, oder? Für eine kurz angepeilte Sendung.
Ja, ja, das kann man jetzt auch mal so langsam.
Genau, sind ja nur drei. Die anderen haben uns hier alleine gelassen. Machen wir einen Topf, Deckel auf den Topf.
Ich würde sagen, das ist eine gute Idee.
Mir fällt das eigentlich nichts mehr ein.
Genau, wenn der Huckel meint, das wäre eine gute Idee, dann kann das eigentlich nur so sein. So ist das mit dem Huckel. Huckel die Hucke. Ich leite hier mal das bittere Ende ein. Ich versuche, das bittere Ende einzuleiten. Das ist ja immer nicht so einfach. Ich habe ja ja, ist ja alles durcheinander und kaputt in diesem Ding. Wunder mich schon wieder, warum ich nichts höre.
Hier passieren Dinge, niemand weiß warum.
Ich werde mal verrückt. Das macht mich wirklich ein bisschen madig hier. Muss ich sagen.
Man denkt an die Lebkuchen. Wenn er schon keine Bitcoins schickt, naja.
Ach manno.
Komm, wir singen die, wir zoomen die Automelodie.
Ja, das wird langsam wirklich Zeit hier. Mein Bitcoin-Signal ist tatsächlich wieder dabei, den Blockchain neu auszurechnen.
Einfach nicht ausmachen, dann stürzt es auch nicht ab.
Mach mich nicht fertig. Ich bin nachhaltig verwirrt.
Die Sendung ist erst zu Ende, wenn die Sendung zu Ende ist, ne?
Ja, ich weiß. Die Sendung ist erst zu Ende, wenn ich in der Lage bin, hier irgendwas abzuspielen.
Stell dir noch, vielleicht hast du jetzt vorhin die Speaker und die Default-Kanäle und alles vertauscht und so.
Ich setze echt komplett aus, mental. Das macht mich alles, macht mich alles wuschig. Ah, jetzt weiß ich, was das Problem ist. Jetzt habe ich es gefunden. Pass auf.
So, wie war das? Jetzt können wir noch ein bisschen quatschen und so, ne? Hast du gesagt?
Es gibt nur zwei Takte und dann ist Schluss.